Le compte à rebours est
officiellement lancé!
- Allô, tout le monde! Pour
poursuivre notre volonté.
- C'est seulement la Parti
conservateur qui peut remplacer
Justin Trudeau.
- Qui pouvait se battre pour
vous, ce NPD.
- Si vous m'accordez votre
confiance, jamais vous n'aurez à
regretter.
- Nous sommes prêts! Le voit
avec le plus de plus de pouvoir
que c'est un.
- Les autres parties ont de
bonnes raisons d'avoir peur de
nous.
- Les par un choix, quelles
actions veulent prendre le pays.
- En direct du musée canadien de
l'histoire à Gatineau, le
partenariat canadien pour la
protection des débats vous
présente le débat des chefs
2019. Voici Patrice Roy.
- Bonsoir et bienvenue à ce
débat des chefs. Bonsoir à tous.
Vos places sur la scène et
l'ordre de parole ont été
déterminé au hasard. Cinq thèmes
seront abordés ce soir, chaque
thème sera lancé par une
question d'un citoyen en direct
après la réponse des chefs, il y
aura de confrontation à trois,
puis des questions rafale des
journées stabilité. Il y a des
citoyens ici au musée de
l'histoire à Gatineau, on vous
remercie d'être ici. Partout à
travers le pays, des
rassemblements ont été
organisés. C'est le dernier
débat de cette campagne, vous le
savez, je compte sur vous, pour
nous donner des réponses claires
et surtout ne pas tous parlaient
en même temps. J'y veillerai.
D'ailleurs, vous verrez parfois
apparaître le temps de parole
cumulatif des chefs. Madame,
Messieurs, bon débat.
- Environnement énergie
- premier thème, environnement
et énergie, nous commençons ce
thème de Trois-Rivières ce soir,
avec une question d'Élisabeth
Darveau. Bonsoir. Vous écoute.
Votre question.
- Dans une heure où nous sommes
de plus en plus cousus toucher
par la cause environnementale
et/ou l'ONU à déclarer l'urgence
climatique, il devient urgent de
prendre les dispositions
nécessaires pour contrer ces
crises. Ma question est la
suivante : sachant que si nous
n'agissons pas maintenant, nous
atteindrons le point de non-
retour. Quel premier changement
concret pensez-vous faire pour
protéger l'environnement?
- Merci beaucoup. Première
épondre : Justin Trudeau.
- Merci pour votre question, on
entend à travers le pays depuis
six plusieurs semaines, on
entend les gens qui disent que
l'avenir de leurs enfants, la de
l'environnement, la lutte contre
les changements climatiques,
c'est essentiel. On a beaucoup
fait sur quatre ans, on doit
continuer et on doit pouvoir
tenir tête contre les
conservateurs comme Jason
Kenney, Doug Ford et les
pétrolières qu'ils appuient pour
pouvoir justement continuer de
lutter contre les changements
climatiques et bâtir un monde
meilleur. C'est pour ça que les
choix que vous faites soit resté
important, mais j'ai confiance
dans les Canadiens, j'ai
confiance dans les prochaines
étapes qu'on va entamer
ensemble.
- Merci beaucoup. M. Bernier.
- Bonsoir, les autres parties
vous disent qu'ils vont
atteindre les cibles de
l'entente de Paris, mais de les
atteindre, parce qu'il faudra
imposer une taxe de 300 de la la
tonne de carbone, les émissions
globales du Canada représentent
seulement 2,6 % des émissions
globales. On veut se concentrer
sur des gestes concrets pour
l'environnement, s'assurer qu'un
au Zoo soit dévaluée, notre sol
et notre ère, je pense qu'on
peut réinvestir pour protéger
réellement notre environnement
et ne pas être hypocrite comme
leader ici autour de moi qui
dise tout faire pour aider les
changements climatiques, mais
dans le fond, et non pas de
solution.
- M. Singh.
- Merci Élisabeth, c'est un
grand jeu, je sais qu'au Québec,
on a eu des inondations sévères,
des feux de forêt, c'est
vraiment un impact réel auquel
on fait passe en ce moment. On a
eu des milliers d'enfants dans
les rues. Propose dès
maintenant, M. Trudeau qui a
acheté un pipeline, on veut
annuler tout de suite toutes les
subventions auprès denrière.
C'est une qu'on peut prendre
tout de suite et on va
réinvestir l'argent dans les
énergies renouvelables, les
énergies propres. On va
réinvestir massivement dans les
transports en commun, on peut
agir, c'est une question d'avoir
le courage, on a le courage.
- Merci. M. Scheer.
- L'environnement, c'est l'un
d'enjeu central de cette
campagne, et comme père de cinq
enfants, je veux m'assurer qu'on
laisse les prochaines génération
une planète plus propre. Malgré
ce que prétend Justin Trudeau
sur ce dossier, son plan est un
échec. Une des premières
décisions qu'il a prises comme
premier ministre, c'est
d'autoriser le déversement de 8
milliards de litres d'eaux usées
dans notre fleuve. On va mettre
fin au déversement d'eaux usées
parce que nous sommes en 2019.
- Merci. M. Blanchet.
- Bonsoir, merci de nous
recevoir chez vous. Il y a
simplement beaucoup de mesures
qui doivent être prises. Je vous
en mentionnerai quelques-unes.
Je pense que le parlement
devrait par le biais d'une loi,
faire en sorte qu'on cesse
immédiatement toute espèce de
subventions aux industries
pétrolières. C'est autour de 10
milliards par année au total,
selon les critères, et une autre
loi pourrait faire en sorte de
contraindre le Canada à
respecter ses. Pour l'instant,
les cibles de 2009 de M. Scheer
sont devenues les cibles de M.
Trudeau et rien n'a été fait
pour les atteindre.
- Merci. Mme May, en terminant.
- Merci, Élisabeth. C'est vrai,
exactement, que vous avez dit,
maintenant, nous sommes trop
proches d'un point de non-
retour, on doit éviter le pire.
Maintenant, si seulement les
verres qui ont un programme qui
est aligné avec les
scientifiques du GIEC. Mais on
doit travailler ensemble, pour
nous, c'est essentiel de mettre
sur pied un cabinet de guerre
comme dans la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale, de faire les choses
ensemble, parce qu'on doit
éliminer la dépendance aux
énergies fossiles et en même
temps changer notre économie
vers une économie plus verte.
- Merci beaucoup. Madame
Darveau, j'espère que vous êtes
éclairé, ce sont les réponses
qui vous ont donné. Merci
beaucoup de votre participation.
Alors, premier trio, première
confrontation à trois, Mme May,
M. Trudeau et M. Blanchet.
Depuis Kyoto, il y a 30 ans, les
politiciens promettent de
diminuer les gaz à. Pour
atteindre les cibles de Paris,
le directeur parlementaire du
budget estime que la taxe sur le
carbone, de 20 $ la tonne, doit
grimpait à 100 $ d'ici les
prochaines années. C'est 23 sous
de plus pour les protestantes.
M. Blanchet vous êtes d'accord
avec le 102, Mme May, vous
proposez 200. M. Trudeau, est-ce
que vous attendez après les
élections pour afficher votre
prix?
- Non, on a un plan pour monter
ce prix jusqu'à 50 $ la tonne
jusqu'en 2020 : ces chiffres de
100 $ la tonne, c'est s'il n'y a
rien d'autre qu'un prix sur la
pollution. On a choisi de faire
d'autres choses aussi. De
protéger la nature encore plus,
d'investir, d'enfiler avec les
centrales de charbon. De manière
le plastique à usage unique. De
planter 2 milliards d'arbres. Ça
prend énormément d'efforts pour
le faire mais on va le faire
parce qu'on n'en fait plus déjà
que tout autre gouvernement dans
l'histoire du pays pour protéger
l'environnement et contrer les
changements climatiques.
- Ce n'est pas suffisant de
parler du prix au carbone.
Endomètre sur pied des cibles
qui sont alliées avec la vie des
scientifiques, maintenant, ce
n'est pas 30 % au-dessus du
niveau de 2005, la cible de M.
Trudeau, même cible que M.
Harper, il est absolument
insuffisant. On doit mettre sur
pied un plan pour l'élimination
de l'énergie fossile d'ici 2050.
Et d'ici 2030,60 % de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre, c'est
vraiment possible. Notre plan
s'appelle mission possible parce
que c'est encore possible. Ce
n'est pas facile, mais c'est
encore possible. Mais ce n'est
pas seulement avec la taxe
carbone.
- Il faudrait arriver pour que
le utilise ne sont pas à
combustion. Il faut mettre une
date là-dessus. Il faut calculer
combien de réduction de l'année,
expression, transport et
consommation. Il ne faut pas
dire qu'on va en parler plus
tard, mais on doit commencer
tout de suite. Ça exclut
évidemment d'aller chercher 173
milliards de de pétrole qu'il
reste en Alberta. C'est
totalement exclu. Sur l'attaque,
on a proposé la péréquation
verte, les promesses sont au-
dessus payes cette taxe et
celles qui sont en dessous
reçoivent cette taxe. C'est
strictement administratif, aucun
changement qui vont mettre en
oeuvre et ça pourrait faire une
oeuvre très incitatif pour tout
le monde.
- Cette initiative est un des
grands défis en tant que chef du
Bloc québécois, pour imposer un
plan tanzanien, ça prend un
gouvernement prêt à le faire, à
tenir tête contre et Silicani,
contre les pétrolières, contre
ceux qui ne veulent rien pour
pour le gouvernement. On veut
lutter contre ça, on n'en a fait
énormément et on reconnaît comme
il faut continuer. C'est pour ça
qu'il ne faut pas arrêter, il
faut que les Québécois, les
Canadiens fassent parti d'un
gouvernement qui veut lutter
contre les changements
climatiques.
- La vraie réalité, c'est que la
situation maintenant est une
situation d'urgence climatique.
Je parle du fond de mon coeur
parce que le temps presse et
tous les ici, il n'y a personne
avec un plan qui marche pour
éviter le pire. Tattooed a
raison : notre maison est en
feu. Deux notre maison est en
feu!
- pire,Qui traversera entre
autres le Québec. Vous dîtes
qu'il n'y a pas de projet,
pourriez-vous imposer un
pipeline?
- Fait partie d'un processus qui
doit avoir l'approbation des
communautés, des peuples
autochtones, travailler avec les
scientifiques pour assurer les
packs. On va procéder, comme on
a procédé avec le lieu-dit Trans
Mountain, pour essayer de
chercher l'approbation de façon
rigoureuse. Les gens savent
qu'il ne faut pas plus de
pétrole par rail, c'est très
dangereux et plus polluant. Il
faut pouvoir mettre les profits
de ce qu'on a besoin maintenant
parce que la transition ne
serait pas tout de suite vers
l'énergie verte, vers la lutte
contre les changements
climatiques et chaque dollar de
profits ira justement pour
l'initiative.
- M. Trudeau, vous proposez
d'utiliser les fonds publics
pour un oléoduc dans une
situation d'urgence publique.
Urgence climatique. On doit
arrêter tous les oléoducs Bruno
Le Maire a été les gaz de
schiste partout au Canada si on
a une seule chance d'éviter le
pire. C'est dans la vie des
scientifiques, ce n'est pas une
question politique, c'est une
question de la réalité.
- Lequel est le Québec ne veut
pas oléoduc, qui ont fait des
propositions et vous les
trouvez, votre seul argument est
que nous ne pouvons pas les
mettre en place. Allez-vous
voter pour la bonne idée peut
venir de n'importe qui.
On a créé un système avec C-69
qui permet d'avoir de
l'approbation pour les mon
projet et les mauvais projets ne
avanceront pas.
- Vous pourriez les poser.
- C'est mieux que... plus de
pétrole sur rail.
- Deuxième confrontation : M.
Singh, M. Bernier et M. Scheer.
Le gouvernement Legault répète
qu'il n'y a pas d'acceptabilité
sociale. M. Bernier et M. sur
l'île vous êtes favorable à, ne
craignez-vous pas, un sentiment
anti Canada au Québec ou un
sentiment anti Québec dans
l'ouest, vous allez de l'avant
et vous imposez un pipeline?
- C'est la raison pour laquelle
je propose mon corridor
énergétique. Je sais que tout le
monde préfère l'énergie de ses
noues. En ce moment, beaucoup
d'argent de nos consommateurs va
aux États-Unis pour acheter le
pétrole aux États-Unis, ça n'a
pas de bon sens. Je vais créer
des conditions où le Québec peut
partager son Hydro et les
ressources naturelles pour être
envoyé de l'Ouest canadien dans
l'Ouest.
- Le corridor énergétique, ça
prendra des années avant que ça
arrive. Ça prend une lieu-dit
pour l'unité du pays, c'est pour
ça que les gens en Alberta
demandent qu'on puisse exporter
notre pétrole qu'un autre marché
que le marché américain. Je ne
suis pas certain que M. Scheer
utilise la condition. Capable de
consolider pipeline. M. Scheer
et M. Trudeau ont la même
position en ce qui concerne les
changements climatiques. La
seule différence, c'est que M.
Scheer va imposer de tarif élevé
au gros émetteur et va donner
des subventions aux pétrolières.
On veut laisser ça aux
provinces, pour les changements
climatiques, on devrait
s'occuper des vraies actions
pour l'environnement.
- Je pense que je peux résumer
la situation ici. M. pipeline,
M. pipeline, M. Trudeau je pense
que c'est pipeline. Moi, je suis
Jagmeet Singh, je ne vais jamais
imposer Québec, c'est clair.
- Le plan actuel de M. Trudeau,
c'était de donner de grandes
exemptions taxe pour les grandes
compagnies. Les contribuables
doivent payer 100 % de la taxe
sur le carbone. Je n'ai aucune
dans mon plan.
- Vous imposez des tarifs élevés
aux grands émetteurs.
- Tu ne vas pas imposer, tu ne
m'as même pas gagné en bourse.
Les Canadiens ne veulent pas
payer la taxe sur le carbone.
Nous ne voulons investir dans
les technologies, nous allons
prendre la lutte contre les
changements climatiques dans un
contexte global, c'est la chose
qui manque dans toutes les
plates-formes.
- Dans un contexte global, M.
Scheer de prendre la voix des
Canadiens pour faire en sorte de
lutter contre les changements
climatiques dans d'autres pays.
Donner encore des millions et
des milliards de dollars pour
lutter contre les changements
climatiques ailleurs. Le plus
important, c'est s'assurer que
l'entraînement ici au Canada
soit protégé. Aujourd'hui, on
encore 215 milliards de litres
d'eaux usées qui sont déversées
dans nos rivières, dans nos
langue innue océans. C'est une
augmentation de 10 % par rapport
à 2013, il faut corriger ça et
investir ici pour les Canadiens
et pour le Canada et non pas
l'étranger.
- On a eu 500 000 enfants dans
les rues à Montréal. Les jeunes
disent qu'il faut agir dès
maintenant. On a M. Trudeau qui,
grand parleur, mais en fait,
c'est un petit faiseur. Il ne
marche pas pour les gens, ne
travaille pas pour les gens. Ce
qu'il faut, c'est donner aux
jeunes de l'espoir. On peut dire
que oui, on peut aller de
l'avant pour annuler les
subventions aux pétrolières,
réinvestir dans les énergies
propres, on peut massivement
investir dans le transport en
commun, il faut agir dès
maintenant.
- M. Bernier M. Scheer, j'ai une
question pour vous. Vous voulez
annuler la taxe carbone, est-ce
que ce n'est pas donné un permis
de polluer avis aux entreprises?
- Absolument pas. Il n'y a pas
de taxe sur la pour le Québec.
La bourse du carbone.
Effectivement, on veut laisser
les provinces de
l'environnement, c'est une
compétence partagée avec le
fédéral et les provinces, notre
plan, les provinces peuvent
s'occuper des changements
climatiques, et le fédéral va
continuer à dépolluer les lacs,
on encore des eaux usées qui
sont jetées, la Ville de
Montréal a fait, et maintenant
la ville de Vancouver. On veut
avoir un environnement plus
propre.
- C'est clair qu'avec M.
Trudeau, avec le plan actuel, il
a donné une grande exemption aux
grands pollueurs. Quand il dit
qu'il pris sur le carbone, ce
n'est pas pour les grands
polluants, c'est seulement pour
les gens ordinaires, les
travailleurs. C'est le problème
avec son approche. Mon approche,
c'est qu'on va mettre une
concentration sur la technologie
par les taxes.
- Le problème, c'est que votre
plan a été écrit par et pour le
secteur pétrolier. Ce n'est pas
acceptable.
- Merci, ça me fait à ce
deuxième trio. Je vous félicite
rapidement pour votre
discipline. Jusqu'ici, ça va
bien. François Cardinal, de La
Presse, vos questions.
- Madame May, je commence avec
vous. Vous voulez réduire les
émissions au pays.
Est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
la décroissance de l'économie
canadienne même si certains
soutiennent que ça pourrait
provoquer beaucoup de perte
d'emploi?
- Merci Monsieur Cardinal. C'est
une question extrêmement
pertinent.
Non, nous ne sommes pas en
faveur de la décroissance de
l'économie canadienne
mais de la transformation de
l'économie canadienne.
Nous avons besoin comme Monsieur
Scheer AD pour l'infrastructure
nationale de corridors mais
seulement pour l'électricité
avec une grande croissance de
notre capacité dans le
renouvelable, énergies
renouvelables.
Nous avons maintenant des
opportunités économiques sans
pétrole.
- Merci. Prochaine question pour
Monsieur Blanchet. Une courte
question pour vous aussi. Vous
êtes très fié de votre
plateforme environnemental. Vous
avez parlé de la péréquation
verte tout à l'heure. Comment
expliquez-vous votre appui
au troisième lien?
- Je n'ai pas dit que j'étais
content ni pour. Pour une raison
simple. Le ministre de
l'environnement a commandé un
BAPE. Je respecte le BAPE. Si on
demanda une institution...
on a proposé par loi qu'elle est
préséance, si on lui demande de
faire l'analyse
environnementale, on va attendre
cette analyse. Ultimement, le
troisième lien va relever
exclusivement du gouvernement du
Québec et non pas du fédéral.
Cette ingérence répétée finie
pas être très excitante. Je suis
convaincu que Québec pour
apprendre une bonne décision
après le BAPE.
- Merci.
Monsieur Scheer. Vous êtes la
pour la lutte aux changements
climatiques mais à condition que
ça passe à l'échelle mondiale.
Est-ce une façon de demander aux
autres pays de faire des efforts
pendant que le Canada continu de
polluer comme si rien n'était?
- Pas du tout. Nous avons une
approche équilibrée, beaucoup de
mesures pour réduire nos
émissions par exemple avec
l'investissement dans la
technologie, le crédit d'impôt
pour les organisations qui
adoptent de nouvelles méthodes.
On doit reconnaître le fait que
le Canada émet seulement 1,6 %
des émissions et si on chasse
tous les investissements et les
emplois, on rend la vie plus
chère pour tous les Canadiens et
envoie l'économie de la Chine et
de l'Inde remplaçait nos
émissions. On accomplit rien.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons une approche
mondiale.
- Merci. Jagmeet Singh, n'était
pas contre l'expansion du
pipeline Trans Mountain.
Vous avez finalement décidé de
vous y opposer au fil de
l'année. Comment comprendre
volte-face sur les projets de
transport de gaz et pétrole?
- Pour moi, c'est clair.
Le futur de notre pays, de notre
planète, c'est un futur on
utilise pas aucune énergie
fossile. C'est l'avenir. Ce que
je vais faire, pour les enfants
qui s'inquiètent de l'avenir,
pour les familles qui font face
aux inondations, pour les gens
qui me disent qu'ils ont peur
des feux de forêt, je vais
mettre tous mes efforts pour
s'attaquer à la crise
climatique. Il faut le faire. On
peut le faire et pour moi, c'est
un engagement fort.
- Merci. Monsieur Trudeau,
vous avez promis en 2015 mettre
fin aux subventions à
l'industrie pétrolière.
Pourtant, vous avez non
seulement acheté un pipeline
pendant votre mandat mais
vous avez aussi offert un
programme d'aide à l'industrie
pétrolière. Comment aujourd'hui
peut-on croire vos promesses
environnementales?
- On est encore en train
d'atteindre nos cibles
d'éliminer les subventions
jusqu'en 2025. Ça prend une
progression. On sait que la
transition ne peut pas se faire
du jour au lendemain. C'est pour
ça qu'on est en train d'investir
de la bonne façon dans l'énergie
verte, renouvelable et tous les
profits, des centaines de
millions de dollars de cet
oléoduc vont aller vers cette
transition, vers la lutte contre
les changements climatiques. On
a un vrai plan parce qu'on a
livré pendant quatre ans. Il
faut continuer. Il faut avoir un
gouvernement fort plein de
Québécois et de francophones qui
vont pouvoir continuer de
contenir les consommateurs qui
ne veulent rien faire.
- Merci Monsieur Trudeau.
Dernière question pour Monsieur
Bernier. Vous êtes le seul chef
a refusé le consensus sur
l'urgence climatique en citant
toujours la même poignée de
détecteur plutôt controversé.
Pourquoi reliez-vous la science?
- Je ne renie pas la séance.
Deuxièmement, il faut bien dire
qu'il y a 500 scientifiques à
travers le monde qui ont écrit
au secrétaire général de l'ONU
pour dire qu'il n'y avait pas
d'urgence climatique. Je ne suis
pas le seul. Il faut bâtir des
politiques publiques non pas sur
des sentiments d'un urgence
climatique qui n'existe pas mais
sur les faits, la raison est ce
qu'on demande, qu'il y a encore
plus d'études sur les pas de
soleil par rapport au changement
climatique, les études
actuellement sont seulement sur
l'impact du CO2. Si vous voulez
vraiment atteindre les cibles,
Élisabeth a raison, elle a
décidé qui vont faire en sorte
qu'on va atteindre les cibles de
Paris, mais elle va détruire
l'économie comme vous l'avez dit
plus tôt. C'est la seule qui est
crédible tout en détruisant
l'économie.
- Merci Monsieur Bernier.
- Merci François. Merci
beaucoup. On est déjà...
à notre deuxième thème :
économie et finances publiques.
Nous avons dans la salle une
citoyenne Marie Saint-Jean qui
veut poser une question. Madame
Saint-Jean. Bonsoir à vous.
Merci d'être là. Votre question,
on vous écoute.
- Lorsqu'on est injecté à la
retraite, il coûte beaucoup plus
cher de vivre seul qu'a 2.
On ne peut pas bénéficier du
partage des revenus, on est seul
pour absorber toutes les
dépenses. Prévoyez-vous
augmenter les pensions des
retraités ou encore majorer la
déduction en raison de l'âge?
En d'autres mots, quelles
mesures fiscales prévoyez-vous
pour aider les personnes âgées
vivant seules?
- Très bonne question. Monsieur
Blanchet, vous répondez en
premier.
- La prémisse que vous mettez en
place, elle est remarquable, il
y a une forte cour qui va
arriver à la retraite qu'il
mérite heureuse et prospère
parce qu'ils ont construit la
société dans laquelle on vit. On
propose une augmentation de 110
$ par mois de leur pension de
vieillesse. Plusieurs crédits
d'impôt sur les activités
physiques, une prolongation du
versement pour le conjoint lors
du décès du conjoint, la
protection des fonds de pension
lors d'une faillite ou la
cessation de l'activité des
entreprises, un ensemble de
mesures je vous invite à
consulter dans le détail. On
répondra à vos questions parce
qu'on pense que c'est important.
- Merci. Monsieur Scheer?
- C'est clair que le coût de la
vie est un enjeu très important
dans cette campagne. C'est le
thème central de notre
plateforme. On va rendre la vie
plus abordable pour tous les
Canadiens et les Québécois
spécifiquement pour les
personnes âgées, les gens qui
ont pris leur retraite. On va
augmenter les crédits en raison
de l'âge de 1000 $.
Beaucoup de chrétiens pouvant
s'appliquer aux personnes âgées
comme le crédit pour le
transport en commun. Aussi, on
va éliminer la TPS pour les
factures... et et pour les
personnes avec un revenu fixé.
C'est important.
- Monsieur Trudeau.
- Merci pour votre question. Une
des premières choses que nous
avons faites, c'est d'augmenter
le supplément de revenu garanti
pour nos aînés les plus
vulnérables, souvent des femmes
seules mais on sait qu'il y a
plus à faire. C'est pour ça
qu'on a promis de bonifier la
sécurité de la vieillesse à
partir de l'âge de 75 ans de 10
%. Si une personne âgée par son
conjoint, c'est un moment
extrêmement difficile et c'est
pour cela qu'on va augmenter
les pensions de survivants, les
régimes des rentes jusqu'à 75 %
de ce qu'il recevait avant. On
sait que d'appuyer nos aînés,
c'est essentiel dans notre
société riche et généreuse comme
la nôtre.
- Madame May.
- Je veux reconnaître que nous
sommes ici sur le terrain des
peuples autochtones non cédés
algonquins. Le parti est
vraiment engagé pour augmenter
le niveau de pension, pour aider
les personnes âgées, moi-même,
j'ai 65 ans, je suis absolument
dans la même position mais je ne
suis pas prête à me retraiter
immédiatement. Je veux mettre
sur pied une stratégie pour les
aînés et mettre sur pied dans le
cabinet fédéral un ministre
avec le but de protéger,
de réduire les coûts pour les
aînés.
- Merci. Monsieur Bernier.
- Tous les autres ici
promettent, ils vous promettent
ce que vous voulez entendre et
faire à sorte qu'on va augmenter
les pensions pour les aînés. Je
vous dis la vérité : la vérité
est que le pays est endetté, on
n'a pas les moyens. La seule
promesse que je vous fais, c'est
d'équilibrer le budget en deux
ans et après ça, seulement après
cela, on va regarder pour
baisser les taxes et les impôts.
Mais les gens ici, il n'y a pas
de limite, pas de difficile, et
c'est comme si rien n'était.
Pour les programmes sociaux,
pour les programmes canadiens,
c'est important d'équilibrer le
budget parce que si jamais il y
a une réception, on aura plus de
marge de manoeuvre. Je ne sais
pas d'acheter votre vote, je
vous dis la vérité.
- Merci. Jagmeet Singh pour
terminer.
- Vous avez soulevé un enjeu qui
touche beaucoup de monde. Merci.
Je pense que c'est ridicule que
les personnes âgées font face à
des grands défis comme ça, des
gens qui ont sacrifié beaucoup,
ils ont le droit d'avoir leur
retraite avec la dignité. Ce
qu'on va faire, c'est de mettre
des programmes pour vous aider.
Il faut augmenter les pensions,
il faut augmenter les services
comme l'assurance médicaments
universelle qui va sauver des
centaines de dollars, les soins
dentaires nationaux qui vont
réduire les coûts et sauver de
l'argent. On veut mettre en
oeuvre...
- merci. Est-ce que vous êtes un
peu plus éclairé pour votre
vote?
- Tous les programmes sont
intéressants, on verra dans
quatre ans.
- Merci beaucoup pour votre
question.
Premier trio économique avec
Jagmeet Singh, Elizabeth May
et Monsieur Blanchet. Aucun de
vous trois proposait des baisses
d'impôts, au contraire, on vient
d'en parler, de nouveaux
programmes coûteux. Vous ne
pensez pas que la classe moyenne
a besoin d'un répit?
- Je pense que la classe moyenne
a besoin d'aide. On ne va jamais
augmenter les taxes sur les
classes moyennes ou les
travailleurs, mais le problème
et les plus riches qui ne paient
pas leur juste part. Ils ont
beaucoup d'argent et ne partage
pas. Ce qu'on veut faire, ce
n'est pas des belles paroles et
pas des actions comme Monsieur
Trudeau, on va mettre en place
une taxe sur les riches. Ça va
donner une augmentation des
revenus de 70 milliards de
dollars.
On peut trouver l'argent si on
veut investir dans les gens. On
a vu l'autre gouvernement qui
investit dans les grandes
compagnies avec des milliards de
dollars, je veux investir dans
les gens parce que je ne
travaille pas pour les plus
riches, je travaille pour vous.
- Moi-même.
Moi aussi je travaille pour les
plus riches. Notre programme,
nous avons le seul programme
dans cette élection chiffrée.
Nous avons une plateforme
chiffrée, nous avons les preuves
de chercher les revenus comme
Jagmeet Singh qui dit que sur
les taxes les plus riches, mais
aussi les taxes sur les gens du
Web comme Facebook et Netflix
et aller chercher les fonds
parce qu'on doit mettre sur pied
plus pour les citoyens du
Canada. Éliminer les frais de
scolarité, investir dans
l'éducation postsecondaire et
nous sommes engagés pour
l'assurance médicaments, mais en
même temps, pour les livraisons
postales à domicile. Toutes les
choses sont possibles pour aider
les personnes âgées mais on doit
choisir les priorités et trouver
les revenus pour équilibrer le
budget en cinq ans.
- Vous êtes sur la glace. À vous
de jouer.
- Petit détail inexact, tout le
monde a déposé des plateforme
financiers qui respectent les
règles en notant que je suis
concerné. Je suis d'accord sur
le principe qu'il faut aller
chercher davantage de revenus
mais il ne faut pas qu'ils
viennent toujours des mêmes
poches. Il est exact qu'il y a
des paradis fiscaux, de
l'évasion fiscale qui favorise
toujours les mêmes, il est exact
qu'on peut faire en sorte avec
les gens du Web, avec une
redevance de 3 %, donc je pense
qu'il doit être réservé, c'est
beaucoup d'argent, on est dans
les centaines de millions de
dollars, ça doit être réservé au
secteur culturel qui en a bien
besoin. Il faut travailler dans
ce sens. On peut regarder les
revenus de la péréquation verte
et mon PC les dépenses du
fédéral. On peut regarder les
400 millions de dollars d'une
déclaration d'impôt unique se
serait sauvé aux contribuables,
aux entreprises et à l'état,
une demande unanime de
l'Assemblée nationale du Québec.
Une demande que le bloc portera
bien sûr. On aura D
conservateurs qui disent être
d'accord et Jagmeet Singh a dit
qu'il était d'accord si il n'y
avait pas de perte d'emploi.
Voici 400 millions de dollars.
- Je veux ajouter un autre
point. C'est une question de
revenus mais aussi une question
de choix. Dans la dernière
année, ce que Monsieur Trudeau
c'est de dépenser beaucoup de
dollars, 14 milliards de dollars
pour les plus riches entreprises
pour qu'il puisse acheter des
avions dans l'économie de
l'OTAN. Il a dit 4,5 milliards
de dollars pour acheter un
pipeline et pour les prêts pour
les grandes compagnies, les
grandes entreprises, il a dit
qu'il allait annuler ces
milliards de dettes pour les
grandes compagnies en général.
Pour moi, c'est 25 millions de
dollars qu'il a donnés aux plus
riches au lieu de donner aux
gens.
- Une petite seconde. On a
beaucoup reçu comme question du
public, c'est l'inquiétude vis-
à-vis cette dette qui grandit et
du déficit. En un mot, vous
trois, est-ce que ça vous
inquiète?
- Le déficit maquette parce que
le gouvernement libéral donne
des milliards de dollars aux
plus riches. Si on prend des
actions pour investir dans les
gens, c'est autre chose.
- Avec notre plateforme
chiffrée, le budget sera
équilibré en cinq ans
101 réceptions. Mais en même
temps, je veux ajouter pour les
subventions vers l'énergie
fossile, elles ont augmenté
depuis les derniers quatre ans.
- Aller chercher l'argent dans
les poches des riches est une
chose, faire en sorte que ça
aille au bon endroit, c'est une
chose. Baisser le déficit en est
une aussi. On ne peut pas couper
le déficit de 19 milliards du
jour au lendemain parce que
l'impact sur l'économie serait
catastrophique. Notre
plateforme, sa baisse de moitié.
Ce n'est pas merveilleux on ne
peut pas aller plus vite. Il
faut aller chercher les revenus
supplémentaires et faire en
sorte que sans aller chercher de
l'argent dans les poches des
contribuables, les entreprises,
les gens du Web, couper les
subventions, revendre Trans
Mountain, ne pas investir dans
sa réflexion règles et des
moyens d'aller chercher beaucoup
d'argent.
- Merci. Deuxième trio sur
l'économie régule Monsieur
Bernier, Monsieur Trudeau et
Monsieur Scheer. Monsieur
Trudeau, vous n'avez pas de plan
de retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire. Monsieur Bernier,
vous voulez couper allègrement,
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure.
Monsieur Scheer, on n'a pas
votre cadre financier. Comment
savoir où vous allez couper?
- J'ai fait un engagement très
clair. On va équilibrer le
budget en cinq ans. Toutes nos
annonces étaient toutes
chiffrées par le directeur
parlementaire du budget. C'est
au contrat de Monsieur Trudeau
qui a présenté une plateforme
écrit sur le coin de la table.
Plus de cent 50 % de ses
engagements...
- on va présenter un cadre
financier. On a présenté un
cadre financier complet,
chiffrée et approuvée
par le directeur parlementaire.
On avait tellement d'ambition
pour les investissements, les
baisses d'impôts pour la classe
moyenne.
On n'a pas baissé les impôts des
plus riches. Vous promettez une
baisse d'impôts de 50 000 $
pour les multimillionnaires.
- Ce sont des mensonges.
(brouhaha)
- vous pouvez finir votre idée.
- Vous avez menti quand le Globe
and Mail a sorti votre histoire,
vous avez menti...
- vous avez baissé les impôts de
la classe moyenne et les
augmenter pour les plus riches.
- 1 à la fois
jusqu'à la fin, Messieurs.
- Je regardais si les chefs des
parties qui vous disent qui vont
équilibrer le budget en cinq ans
et vous demande un mandat de
quatre ans. Personne ne va
équilibrer le budget. Monsieur
Scheer va additionner 70
milliards de dollars sur la
dette, Monsieur Trudeau va faire
la même chose. C'est
irresponsable. Les finances
publiques, on ne peut plus
additionner. La carte de crédit
national est pleine. La seule
promesse que je fais, c'est des
coupures. On peut couper les
subventions aux entreprises,
Monsieur Scheer va continuer et
Monsieur Trudeau aussi. Si on
veut relancer l'économie, il
faut remettre de l'argent dans
la poche des entrepreneurs,
les entrepreneurs de partout. On
va trouver l'argent pour
équilibrer le budget.
- Merci Monsieur Bernier.
- On l'a entendu bien souvent,
on l'a vu depuis 10 ans ou
Monsieur Harper vous faisiez
parti de ce parti, on a vu des
coupures, des baisses d'impôts
pour les mieux nantis, des souys
investissements dans l'écriture
et ça n'a pas livré une
croissance économique. Depuis
quatre ans, des investissements
dans la classe moyenne, on a vu
1 million d'emplois créés. On a
vu les plus bas taux de chômage
de l'histoire du pays et 900 000
personnes sortirent de la
pauvreté.
- Il y a trop de mensonges dans
ce discours pour lesquels pas le
temps de répondre.
C'est l'excuse pour les grands
déficits de Justin Trudeau,
c'était de dépenser l'argent
dans les infrastructures. Et le
directeur du budget
parlementaire a dit qu'il n'y a
aucun plan.
On a le pire des demandes. On
alléguant déficits et aucun
projet d'infrastructure.
Le coût de ces déficits augmente
et augmente. De plus en plus
d'argent des contribuables doit
aller pour payer l'intérêt.
- M. Trudeau, M. Bernier.
- Aucun investissement en effet
toute personne peuvent aller
voir dans leur ville, les
investissements en transport en
commun, les investissements en
logement salarial, les
investissements ne pas parce que
les consommateurs sont Stephen
Harper on sous investi et nous
on a fait le choix d'investir de
façon raisonnable dans notre
avenir et ça fonctionne.
- Vous avez créé un déficit et
vous avez créé actuellement
l'intérêt sur la dette
seulement, c'est 26 milliards de
dollars par année. Il n'y a plus
de marge de manoeuvre. C'est
irresponsable. Actuellement,
plus un économiste dise qu'on
risque de s'en aller vers une
récession dans quelques années.
Et si c'est le cas, ça va être
désastreux pour les programmes
sociaux. Il faut avoir une
politique responsable et ce
n'est pas en dépensant les
entraînements que vous créez de
la richesse. Il faut que nos
entrepreneurs puissent de large.
- Des investissements dans les
jambes dans les travailleurs
dans les familles, ça crée de la
résilience dans les familles,
dans les communautés. Ce n'est
pas de garder un groupe
d'argents pour quand on n'en a
besoin. On sait que de donner
des investissements rouges pour
faire de la résilience, c'est ça
qui va créer des opportunités
dans nos temps difficiles dans
l'avenir. On est en désaccord
là-dessus. On le comprend.
- M. Trudeau...
vos chiffres, M. Scheer.
- Justin Trudeau a augmenté la
dette fiscale pour tous les
Canadiens, il a augmenté les
impôts pour 80 % des familles de
l'. Nous avons proposé un plan
économique pour équilibrer le
budget dans cinq ans.
- On ne l'a pas vu encore!
- Plus de 50 % de vos
engagements n'ont aucun chiffre.
- Très bien, merci, merci. Fin
du bloc. C'est normal, ça c'est
sûr. Pensez aux gens à la
maison, pensez aux gens à la
maison. À qui vous voulez
envoyer vos messages en même
temps. Ça ne passe plus.
Hélène Buzzetti, bonsoir.
Question recherche?
- M. Scheer, on commence avec
vous. D'abord très rapidement
parce que plusieurs citoyens
nous ont écrit à ce sujet.
Allez-vous changer l'âge de la
retraite qui est à 65 ans?
- Non.
- On a toujours pas votre cadre
financier mais vous voulez
rééquilibrer le budget en cinq
ans. Le précédent gouvernement
conservateur avec dans la
culture et la recherche
scientifique. Vous, est-ce que
vous allez faire la même chose
pour éliminer le déficit?
- Alors nous avons déjà annoncé
les endroits où on va trouver de
l'argent pour lesquelles va
protéger la culture et les
investissements dans les
technologies et la recherche. On
va éliminer 1,5 milliards de
dollars pour les subventions
corporatives et on va couper
l'aide étrangère par 25 %.
On va garder cet argent ici chez
nous. Lorsqu'on peut rendre la
vie plus abordable va baisser
les impôts, on va réintroduire
les impôts pour les sports.
- Le recensement reste? D'accord
pour l'pour M. Bernier. Vous
avez promis d'abolir la gestion
de l'offre en agriculture alors
qu'on parle de plus en plus
d'acheter et de manger local.
Qu'est-ce que vous dites aux
consommateurs qui ont peur de
voir leurs tapisseries remplies
de produits des États-Unis,
comme les Américains?
- Les producteurs Canada vont
devoir respecter les normes
sanitaires canadiennes. Le plus
important c'est que chaque
famille canadienne va sauver 400
$ par année. Si on est sérieux,
il faut abolir ce système qui
est un système socialiste,. Mais
le plus important M. Scheer tout
à l'heure qu'il va équilibrer le
budget équilibrer le budget, il
suffit de couper la n'a pas
empêché Kim économiser 5
milliards là-bas. On doit
récupérer cet argent il faut
canarder pour aider les Canada.
Une chose qu'on peut faire pour
aider les plus démunis, c'est
abolir sages cartels de la de ou
les familles canadiennes vont
économiser.
- Mme May, votre cadre financier
a été démoli parce que vous
proposez d'ajouter 70 milliards
de dépenses dès la première
année. Comment allez-vous
convaincre les électeurs que
vous êtes crédible en matière de
finances publiques?
- Parce que notre plate-forme
chiffrait a été étudiée par
l'institut fiscal pour la
démocratie avec l'ancien
directeur du bureau
parlementaire du budget,
Monsieur Page. Il a donné au
budget une bonne note. Oui, mais
c'est vrai, nous sommes la vraie
avec un programme compréhensible
et chiffré. La réalité, c'est
qu'on doit faire plus. Nous
sommes un pays riche, on doit
augmenter notre système pour
justice sociale, on doit faire
plus pour les soins des enfants,
pour la garderie, pour les
personnes âgées, et c'est
vraiment possible.
- Merci. M. Trudeau, en 2015,
vous proposez des déficits pour
investir dans les espaces sur
les électeurs vous ont suivi. En
2000, vous proposez encore de
vivre à crédit, d'alourdir la
dette de 100 milliards pour des
dépenses courantes. Si jamais il
y a une récession, quelle marge
de manoeuvre aurait vous?
- On croit que l'important,
c'est de pouvoir aider nos
jeunes à trouver de bons
emplois, avoir l'éducation
nécessaire, aider les familles à
pouvoir offrir des opportunités
à leurs enfants pour qu'il
puisse grandir en sécurité avec
toutes les opportunités qu'il
pourrait avoir. Ces
investissements, ça a fonctionné
pendant quatre ans. On a vu 900
000 personnes sorties de la
pauvreté.
- Mais s'il y a une récession,
est-ce qu'on va avoir des ou
est-ce qu'on aura des déficits
jusqu'à trois fois plus élevées?
- On va avoir des marges de
manoeuvre parce que notre plan a
été coté AAA par les agences de
crédit il y a seulement
l'Allemagne et le Canada qui ont
un crédit unanime de premier
plan parce que notre plan est
responsable et raisonnable sur
le cadre fiscal.
- Merci. M. Singh, comme mystère
Scheer, n'avait pas de cadre
financier mais vous savez, vous
promettez des plans très courtes
comme l'assurance médicaments et
l'assurance à payer les riches
mais les experts disent qu'on se
reste toujours la pour aller
chercher de ce côté. C'est
connu, les riches ont de bons
fiscalistes. Comment allez-vous
dissiper l'impression que votre
plan relève un peu de la pensée
magique?
- Ce qu'on va faire, sait-on
parce que c'est important de le
faire. Oui, c'est difficile de
faire les bonnes choses, mais on
a le courage de le faire quand
même. Mais aussi, on a choisi
des chiffres tellement
spécifiques parce que on le
sait, la taxe sur les très
riches pour les gens qui ont
presque 20 millions de dollars,
remettre une taxe de 1 % parce
qu'on a évalué que avec 1 %,
c'est plus difficile pour
échapper l'argent que de le
payer. Donc on est allé par
expert pour faire ça. Mais on
sait qu'en général si on
augmente le financement pour le
revenu, de s'assurer qu'à ce
revenu là, on peut le faire.
Avec le financement des employés
qui cherchent de l'argent dans
notre gouvernement, on peut le
faire.
- Merci. M. Blanchet, vous êtes
contre les pipelines mais vous
ne dénoncez toujours pas le
gazoduc GNA Québec qui se rendra
jusqu'à Saguenay. Dites-nous,
est-ce que vous opposez aux
hydrocarbures seulement lorsque
c'est l'Alberta qui empêche les
profits?
- En toute cohérence, et j'ai
déjà répondu un peu à ça plutôt,
il y a un bureau d'audiences
publiques sur le projet de GNL.
J'ai été assez clair sur le fait
que je pense que les énergies de
l'hydrocarbure et facile ne sont
pas l'avenir, ce n'est pas là
qu'il faut aller, ce projet-là
qu'il faut réaliser. Cohérence,
commencée ministre de
l'environnement, j'attends le
rapport du BAPE et je ne
m'attends pas ce que le BAPE
soit favorable à GNL. On va
attendre. On voit aussi que le
BAPE est préséance sur les
évaluations de mental fédéral.
On va prendre position sur cet
enjeu une fois qu'on aura le
rapport. Je m'attends à ce que
le BAPE soit passablement
sévère.
- Merci.
- Merci, Hélène, provocateur.
C'est la fin de ce deuxième
thème. Prochain thème :
service aux citoyens.
- Service aux citoyens. Nous
avons pour débuter ces thèmes un
citoyen à Toronto à Mississauga,
très honnêtement. Monsieur
Gravel, les chefs vous écoutent.
(Des services en français pour
les minorités francophones hors
Québec. On vous écoute.
- Bonsoir. Mesdames et
Messieurs., Vivre dans une
minorité est un défi. Avec les
récente coûts provinciale, c'est
devenu encore plus difficile.
Sur le plan fédéral, ce n'est
pas mieux non plus parce que les
services sont difficiles à
avoir. Par exemple, demander à
un préposé au bureau des
passeports de le rencontrer,
vous venez de multiplier par 10
votre temps d'attente. Elle
canardait, avoir un agenda
Barrois préposé qui parle
français à Toronto, ça relève
presque du miracle. Malgré les
plaintes, les nombreuses
plaintes auprès du commissaire,
les choses ne changent pas. Ma
question est la suivante :
comment est concrètement, et
quels outils de Trévoux le
commissaire aux langues
officielles pour qu'il puisse
enfin faire respecter cette loi
et donner à tous les
francophones du Canada un
service adéquat et équivalent
aux autres?
- Très clair comme question. M.
Scheer premier à répondre.
- Merci pour la question. C'est
un enjeu très important. Peut-
être que ça va être une surprise
mais le français n'est pas ma
première langue. Je suis natif
d'Ottawa et c'est grâce à une
décision de mes parents
anglophones que j'ai appris le
français dans une école
d'immersion. J'ai fait de grands
efforts, j'apprends mon
subjonctif malgré l'imparfait de
mes paroles. J'ai toujours
essayé d'améliorer mon français.
Concrètement, j'ai eu une
réunion, organisée une réunion
entre tous les chefs de parti
fédéral pour régler le problème
avec université francophone. Je
vais appuyer, j'ai fait un
engagement très pour appuyer
cette université et j'ai proposé
de moderniser la loi sur les
langues officielles.
- Merci, Mme May.
- Merci Monsieur Gravel, cette
question très important parce
que ça fait trop longtemps que
nous n'avons pas modernisé la
loi sur les langues officielles.
On doit le faire. Et parce que
vous avez demandé des réponses
concrètes, la chose que je pense
que c'est très important, c'est
de donner au commissaire des
langues officielles pouvoir de
punir. Plus de pouvoir pour
exiger que toutes les agences
dans le domaine fédéral puisse
présenter les services adéquats
et égaux dans les deux langues
officielles dans la première
année de mon mandat.
- M. Bernier :
- c'est très important. Le
fédéral devrait réinvestir dans
ses champs de compétence pour
les langues officielles et pour
les autres services que le
gouvernement fédéral offre aux
citoyens. Vous avez déjà autour
de vous, des leaders de partis
qu'ils vous disent qu'ils vont
investir dans le logement social
dans la santé, dans l'éducation.
Ce sont des champs de
juridiction provinciale. Et
nous, notre politique de
respecter la constitution
canadienne, ne pas s'ingérer
dans les champs de compétence
provinciale et de redonner les
ressources au gouvernement
fédéral pour s'assurer de donner
les bons services en français
aux francophones à l'extérieur
du Québec et en anglais
anglophones, mais aussi les
autres services dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure : un
gouvernement fédéral fort mais
dans ses champs de compétence.
- M. Blanchet :
- les Québécois savent ce que
c'est qu'être une minorité parce
que même si les Québécois
francophones du Québec sont
majoritaires au Québec, on est
très, très minoritaire en
Amérique en antériorité d'ont
trouvé ça étrange mais les
francophones hors Québec et les
Acadiens sont nos frères et nos
soeurs francophones à l'ensemble
du continent et du Canada. Je
pense que le commissaire aux
langues officielles pour bien
faire son travail doit ramener
la notion de réciprocité. Il
faut que les communautés
francophones à l'extérieur du
Québec et la communauté
acadienne et le même niveau de
service que les communautés où
la communauté anglophone
hystérique et précieuse Québec,
et il faut que les francophones
au Canada et les Acadiens et le
même niveau de service que les
Anglais du Québec.
- Merci. M. Singh.
- Merci, Monsieur Gravel, pour
la question. Comme vous pouvez
l'entendre, je ne suis pas
francophone mais je suis
fortement francophile. Je
l'avais pas de mesure de classe
en français mais pendant mon
enfance, je suis tombé en amour
avec la langue française, la
langue de Molière. Et je vais
partager cette richesse parce
que c'était une richesse dans ma
vie. Ce que nous voulons faire
concrètement, c'est de
moderniser les langues
officielles, de mieux finançait
les services en français parce
qu'il faut le faire. Si le
gouvernement peut faire quelque
chose, on veut faire quelque
chose, il le fait. C'est une
question de courage, c'est une
question de volonté. On a la
volonté parce que c'est
tellement important.
- Merci. M. Trudeau.
- Merci, Monsieur Gravel pour
votre question. Vous souviendrez
longtemps comme moi de ce que
Doug Ford a fait, de couper dans
les services francophones,
malgré qu'il s'était dit pour
les gens quand il s'était fait
élire, mais c'est ça que font
les conservateurs. On a su
défendre les minorités
francophones en Ontario et à
travers le pays. On va continuer
de le faire. On a fait un
investissement record dans les
communautés francophones ou des
communautés de langue officielle
en situation minoritaire à
travers le pays, et on s'est
engagé à moderniser la loi sur
les langues officielles. On
comprend la lutte que vous vivez
à tous les jours et on sera
toujours avec vous.
- Merci. Je remercie surtout
Monsieur Gravel d'avoir posé
cette question. Merci. J'espère
que ça vous a éclairé, Monsieur
Gravel. Merci.
- Merci.
- Premier trio sur ce thème de
services aux citoyens, M. Singh,
M. Scheer et M. Blanchet.
Vous êtes donc questionné. Vous
pouvez interagir aussi. On a
parlé, je parle de la question
autochtone, on a parlé de
génocide culturel, on a parlé
des pensionnats, des femmes
disparues, de réserves en
logement ou eau potable. La
question est très simple, elle
ne peut être plus simple :
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
concrètement pour améliorer les
conditions de vie des
autochtones? M. Scheer, pardon
M. Singh, je commence avec vous.
- J'ai encore mis le turban
orange pour éviter ce problème,
mais bon. On continue quand
même.
En fait, c'est une question
tellement sérieuse.
Ce que j'ai vu, M. Trudeau a
donné beaucoup de belles paroles
au public mais c'est vraiment,
la décision qu'il a faite en
privé, c'est ça le problème.
Avec les communautés
autochtones, c'est clair, si on
veut agir dès maintenant, on
peut agir. Donc la question,
c'est cela. Si on respecte le
fait que les enfants autochtones
ont le droit d'avoir le même
financement, il ne faut pas les
poursuivre en cours de justice
comme M. Trudeau a fait. Ce que
je fais, je vais respecter la
communauté autochtone. Ça, c'est
primordial, c'est la première
étape, c'est le respect et la
dignité. Si on commence avec ça,
ça veut dire qu'on va mieux les
finances pour les communautés
autochtones avec un financement
égal.
- C'est un débat. M. Scheer M.
Blanchet.
- Merci beaucoup. Un aspect de
respecter les Premières Nations,
c'est de respecter dans les
communautés autochtones dise oui
à des projets pour aider la
croissance économique. Et quand
on parle des communautés dans
les endroits éloignés ou
rurales, il y a des secteurs qui
créent le plus d'emplois pour
les Premières Nations, ce sont
les secteurs miniers, forestier
et le secteur énergétique. Et
c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai dit que je vais nommer un
ministre avec la responsabilité
de faire les consultations de
manière dynamique pour assurer
qu'on respecte nos obligations
comme gouvernement avec les
traités.
- Les relations avec les
premiers peuples sont marquées
par un déficit de confiance
parce que, sa compréhension et
ses 50 avoirs parce que ce sont
de véritables nations, avec les
mêmes droits, privilèges,
obligations et responsabilités
que les véritables nations. Mais
il y a déclaration de l'ONU, il
y a des enquêtes, il y a des
études, il y a des commissions
et disent, et ceux qui le disent
que je suis à l'aise parce que
c'est doit venir de, qu'il n'y a
pas de suite concrète, qu'on ne
met pas en oeuvre des démarches,
qu'on fait tout ce qui est
théorique est beau, et pendant
ce temps, les solutions ne se
trouvent pas, le respect ne
s'établit pas, la confiance ne
se construit pas. Il va falloir
modifier notre relation profonde
avec les premiers peuples en
disant que un peuple ou une
nation, ce n'est pas qu'un mot
de cette réalité à laquelle ils
ont droit comme nous.
- Je suis tellement d'accord
avec ce que M. Blanchet a dit :
si on parle de respect, j'ai
visité une communauté
empoisonnée par le mercure.
M. Trudeau, dans des événements
privés, il s'est moqué de
quelqu'un qui a milité pour dire
que notre eau est empoisonnée,
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire.
Il a dit : merci pour votre
donné. C'est complètement
incompréhensible comme quelqu'un
peut faire ça si on a visité
cette communauté, on a vu les
impacts de l'empoisonnement sur
le corps des gens. Comment les
enfants tremblent à cause de cet
empoisonnement. Je n'ai pas de
mots pour dire comment quelqu'un
peut dire ça, ce n'est pas
quelque chose qu'il possédait.
- J'arrête le chronomètre sur
cela. Comme vous avez pointé M.
Trudeau sur une question très
précise, je vous donne M.
Trudeau pour répondre à cette
question, si on peut ouvrir la
lumière de M. Trudeau.
- Merci. Nous avons fait
beaucoup d'investissement pour
investir les communautés
autochtones à travers le pays.
Avec celle mentionnée avec
l'empoisonnement au mercure, on
a travaillé avec eux pour
approuver un centre de
traitement et on va donner le
financement nécessaire pour ce
centre de traitement.
- C'est un peu choquant, on
trouve des milliards de dollars
pour acheter des oléoducs, mais
on ne trouve pas d'argent pour
donner de l'eau potable pour des
communautés autochtones. C'est
fondamental, élémentaire, un
minimum de respect et de dignité
des peuples qui sont autant
d'épreuves que nous, s'il vous
plaît.
- Il faut reconnaître que tous
les partis se sont succédé et
constate que c'est très
difficile d'avoir des
améliorations concrètes. M.
Scheer.
- C'est un défi, mais c'est
essentiel que nous avons un
gouvernement qui prend ses
responsabilités sérieusement.
C'est mon engagement pour les
Premières Nations. On va
s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas
seulement des investissements,
mais un nouveau système pour
s'assurer que l'investissement
fonctionne. Ce n'est pas
seulement une question d'argent,
c'est aussi de rétablir la
dynamique dans les départements.
J'ai proposé de modéliser les
lois pour les Premières Nations
pour qu'ils puissent bénéficier
des ressources naturelles sur
les réserves.
- Selon vous, si les ressources
naturelles. Et vous, la
réconciliation.
- On a eu des gouvernements
conservateurs et libéraux qui
ont choisi de négliger les
communautés autochtones. C'est
ça. Ils ont eu la chance de le
faire, qu'ils peuvent faire pour
le secteur pétrolier, il saute
pour acheter un pipeline, pour
donner des subventions.
- S'il vous plaît, faites-le
avec les Premières Nations, ne
les posez pas, ils ont le droit
de participer aux décisions.
- Nous allons poursuivre sur le
thème des Autochtones. Pourquoi,
c'est très récent, vous étiez en
appel d'un jugement qui vous
ordonnait au gouvernement de
verser 40 000 $ à des enfants
autochtones confiés à la
protection de l'enfance. Vous ne
deviez pas être le champion
justement de la réconciliation?
- Oui, on les et on continue de
l'être. On est d'accord avec le
tribunal qu'il faut absolument
compenser ses enfants et on va
le faire, on va travailler avec
eux pour établir les bons
niveaux. Mais on a pu faire des
investissements concrets au
cours des quatre dernières
années, on a levé 87 évolution
avis d'ébullition, on a pu créer
de nouvelles écoles de nouveaux
investissements en partenariat
avec les peuples autochtones. On
comprend qu'il faut continuer,
il y en a beaucoup plus à faire,
mais le grand chef de
l'assemblée des Premières
Nations a reconnu qu'aucun
gouvernement n'en avait plus et
on reconnaît qu'on anal plus à
faire.
- M. Trudeau, ce n'est pas vrai
parce que les tribunaux de
renommée ont eu décisions et
votre gouvernement a contesté
les résultats. Ce n'est pas vrai
que vous avez dit que vous êtes
à l'aise avec les décisions. Les
avocats ont fait un effort de
renverser le jugement en faveur
des enfants autochtones. Qu'est-
ce qu'on peut faire pour ça,
c'est un vrai scandale!
- On est d'accord avec le
tribunal qu'il faut compenser
ses enfants.
- Pourquoi avoir fait appel, M.
Trudeau?
- Parce que l'échéancier de le
faire d'ici décembre ne
fonctionne pas avec les
élections qu'on est en train de
faire maintenant. On va
compenser ses enfants, mais ça
prend un peu de temps pour le
faire de la bonne façon.
- On encore des problèmes
aujourd'hui, et n'ont pas d'eau
potable, ce n'est pas une
question d'argent pour livrer ce
service. Il y a 21 milliards de
dollars que le gouvernement
dépense pour les relations avec
les Premières Nations. Ça fait
des années qu'on essaie de bâtir
meilleures relations avec les
Premières Nations. Il faut
abolir la loi sur les Indiens,
il faut s'assurer qu'il y a plus
d'autonomie sur les réserves, il
faut se de développer un droit
de propriété sur les réserves,
il faut que la richesse crée sur
les réserves et il faut
développer les pipelines en
collaboration avec la pronation
que la richesse arrivé sur les
réserves, c'est une question de
changer notre relation avec les
Premières Nations.
- Je suis tout à fait d'accord
qu'il faut passer au-delà de la
loi sur les Indiens, mais c'est
à eux de décider le rythme avec
lequel ça se fait. Plusieurs
commodités l'ont déjà fait, on
travaille tous pour qu'il puisse
le faire, mais à leur rythme et
dans le respect de leurs
priorités.
- On va rouvrir les lumières
pour les six en régie parce que
je vous posais la question sur
la culture. On a abordé trop
rapidement tout à l'heure. Vous
promettez, un certain nombre
d'entre vous promettez d'imposer
ou de taxer les géants du Web.
Vous engagez-vous à remettre cet
argent au créateur, aux artistes
qui produisent des contenus et
qui reçoivent, On va se le dire,
des miettes.
- On va en faire plus que juste
des recettes en investissement
culture.
- C'est notre proposition. 3 %
de redevance, ils exploitent
commercialement des contenus qui
ne leur appartiennent pas, des
centaines de millions de dollars
par année réservée aux médias, à
la culture et au divertissement.
40 % réservés aux acteurs
francophones.
- On va imposer une taxe sur les
géants du Web qui ramasse
beaucoup d'argent ici de notre
économie et on va s'assurer que
cet argent va pour appuyer nos
programmes. Aussi, on va créer
une nouvelle régie pour les
nouveaux médias numériques parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens... et
aucun rêvé venue parce que les
géants ramassent tout l'argent.
- C'est inéquitable actuellement
que les gens ne payent pas, ses
grandes Webb ne paient pas de
TPS, il faut qu'il appelle comme
les autres. L'argent qu'on va
avoir, c'est la juridiction du
Canada, après l'équilibre
budgétaire, on veut réinvestir.
- Une source de revenus pour ce
que vous proposez, pour aider
les artistes pour donner les
revenus vers notre communauté
culturelle, mais je veux ajouter
une chose, ce n'est pas vrai que
le premier ministre a dit que
les tribunaux des droits humains
pour les peuples autochtones,
s'est ouvert gouvernement de
demander plus de temps.
- M. Trudeau flash à gauche
pendant la campagne, dit tout ce
qu'il veut, mais tourne à droite
au gouvernement. Il faut
accélérer entre Web et oui il
faudrait réinvestir dans les
artistes, les créateurs.
- Merci de votre collaboration.
Je pense que c'était clair pour
les gens qui nous regardent.
J'appelle Patricia Cloutier,
bonsoir. Elle va vous poser des
questions rafale. Accélérer le
rythme, l'expression très
concrète.
- J'attends des réponses courtes
de 15 secondes environ. Des
millions de Canadiens se sont
faits voler ces derniers mois
leurs données personnelles.
Êtes-vous prêt à faire comme la
Grande-Bretagne et à pénaliser
les rangs entreprises
responsables d'une fuite de
données?
- Oui, les bonnes responsables
de garder la vie privée des
gens, quand on a des situations
qui comme ça avec les banques ou
la vie privée est brisée, c'est
la responsabilité des banques et
oui, il faut avoir des
répercussions.
- Oui, on a créé une charte pour
défendre les droits numériques
des citoyens, on travaille avec
la Grande-Bretagne et la France
pour s'assurer que les citoyens
puissent avoir contrôle de leurs
données, avant le contrôle de
leurs informations.
- Nous proposons au Parlement
que... que les mesures
d'identification des clients
soient beaucoup plus. Que les
déclarations soient faites,
chaque fois qu'il y a de plus de
renseignements, il faut que
l'entreprise déclare la fuite de
renseignements et couvre les
frais encourus par les clients.
- Oui, la protection des
renseignements personnels et
aucune entreprise et aussi de la
loi.
- On doit protéger les Canadiens
contre les choses comme ça, les
banques sont négligentes et on
doit protéger les droits des
consommateurs.
- Oui, on va protéger les
consommateurs, les Canadiens et
s'assurer l'intégrité de leurs
données. Mais je dois dire que
c'est le gouvernement de Justin
Trudeau qui a essayé de donner
la permission à Statistique
Canada pour ramasser les
formations sans le consentement
des Canadiens. C'est
inacceptable. Les données
financières, bancaires, vous
avez donné la permission, si
seulement quand l'opposition...
- on n'est pas dans un moment de
débat. Une autre question. Les
Canadiens attendent depuis
longtemps un train à grande
fréquence entre Québec et
Toronto. Vous engagez-vous à
réaliser ce projet de transport,
si oui, quand?
- C'est un engagement de notre
plafond, parce que ça touche
comment on peut faire face à la
crise climatique en
investissement dans le transport
en commun. On est pour le train
à grande fréquence que c'est un
élément de comment on peut
réduire nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre.
- C'est nous qui chapeautant le
projet, on sait assurer que ça
passe par Trois-Rivières, que ça
se rende à Québec, il y a encore
du travail là-dessus, mais on
est un gouvernement qui a choisi
d'investir dans les
infrastructures, contrairement
au gouvernement conservateur,
dont les qui ne veulent pas
investir.
- On en parle tout le temps, on
ne le voit jamais. Il a été
promis par les libéraux en 2015,
je me rappelle, on dit même que
ça allait arrêter à Shawinigan.
Cette année, ils disent qui vont
faire une étude parce qu'ils ne
sont pas sûrs. On n'est pas sur
le bord d'embarquer dans le
train.
- Tout le monde promet des
investissements avec de l'argent
qu'on n'a pas, il faut le dire,
ce qu'on dit, c'est que non, il
faut équilibrer le budget en
premier et on le commencera pas
à plaire à tout le monde pour
avoir des votes. Ce n'est pas
responsable voulant dépenser des
milliards de dollars quand il y
a d'autres choses à pour
équilibrer le budget.
- C'est absolument dans notre
plan mission possible, on doit
mettre sur pied un système de
transport en commun de côte à
côte et aussi
- On va le faire, mais surtout
d'occuper les promesses.
- Il pourra prendre le train un
jour de plus merci beaucoup.
- Prochain thème : politique
étrangère et immigration. Nous
ne débutons avec un citoyen, il
est à Dieppe, au Nouveau-
Brunswick. Philippe merciles,
vous êtes à l'université de
Moncton. Bonsoir à vous, les
vous écoute.
- Bonsoir. Vous seul le soleil,
avec l'emprisonnement des deux
Canadiens, les nombreux
manquements face aux droits
humains en Chine, seriez-vous
prêt à cesser les échanges
commerciaux si la situation ne
s'améliore pas?
- Merci beaucoup.
- La priorité est bien claire,
c'est de faire en sorte que les
Canadiens et de retour au Canada
et actuellement, c'est que les
relations avec la Chine, qui
sont à leur meilleur, mais pas
seulement la Chine, avec
d'autres pays à cause
gouvernement Trudeau. Ce serait
une priorité. Il faut avoir les
deux nos alliés, mais aussi en
regardant nos relations hheennii
ça peut être quelque chose va
évaluer pour imposer des tarifs
si on n'a pas la réponse à ce
qu'on veut, c'est rapatrier ses
Canadiens le plus rapidement
possible. Et aussi, c'est
important de s'assurer qu'on est
des bonnes relations avec
l'ensemble des autres pays, avec
M. Trudeau, avec les États-Unis,
on n'a pas la meilleure entente,
avec l'aide aussi.
- On reconnaît que la priorité
est toujours de défendre les
intérêts des Canadiens et de
défendre les Canadiens, c'est
pour cela qu'on a justement fait
activer nos alliés autour de la
planète pour mettre de la
pression sur la Chine pour leur
dire que non, ça ne se fait pas
de détenir de façon arbitraire
des Canadiens pour une raison
politique. On va continuer de
chercher à résoudre cet enjeu
tout en reconnaissant que la
Chine est une économie en
croissance qui prend beaucoup
plus de place et qui crée des
opportunités économiques pour
nos producteurs, nos
travailleurs, mais nous devons
toujours être là pour défendre
nos valeurs, nos principes et
c'est ce que nous allons
toujours faire.
- C'est pas une grande surprise
que le gouvernement de la Chine
ne respecte pas Justin Trudeau.
Après son voyage désastreux en
Inde, beaucoup de chefs d'État
du G20 qui ne respecte pas. M.
Trudeau n'a rien fait pendant
neuf mois pour protéger les
Canadiens, les intérêts des
Canadiens. J'ai dit que comme
premier ministre, je vais
retirer l'argent Canadiens de la
banque infrastructures
asiatique. C'est une banque qui
a été contrôlée par le
gouvernement de la Chine. Il y a
aucune bonne raison que l'argent
des contribuables soit pour
construire des ponts et des dans
les autres pays et qui appuie
les politiques étrangères de la
Chine.
- La priorité, ce sont les
Canadiens qui en ce moment sont
dans une situation tellement
difficile. Il faut agir dès
maintenant pour les aider. C'est
quelque chose qui est essentiel.
En plus, oui, la question est-ce
qu'il faut faire avec la Chine,
il faut être fort pour montrer
qu'on défend les droits de la
personne, ce qui se passe à Hong
Kong, c'est tellement
inquiétant, le fait que les gens
fassent face à autant de
dépression. M. Trudeau dit
toutes les bonnes choses, mais
va tourner à droite qu'il est au
gouvernement, pourquoi il a pas
arrêté de vendre des armes...
- merci, Philippe. Nous avons un
éléphant dans la chambre, c'est
le fait que M. Scheer a accepté
avec la Chine, le traité, ce
n'est pas un seul vote, c'est un
traité énorme avec les
investisseurs de la république
de la Chine qui ont donné déjà
les droits des entreprises de la
Chine de charger le Canada quand
nous avons les lois que la Chine
n'aime pas, contre les lois pour
protéger l'environnement, et
c'est tout à fait en secret.
C'est quelque chose de mauvais.
- Permettez-moi d'avoir une
pensée pour les agriculteurs sur
la gestion de l'offre, parce que
de mauvaises négociations
commerciales leur ont coûté 24 %
de leurs parts de marché. Il
s'est pogné une chicane avec la
Chine. La réponse, c'est qu'on
ne peut pas être en chicane
perpétuelle avec un géant, on
peut pas jouer avec la Chine que
c'est impossible. Ce sont les
producteurs de porc, de soja et
de canola qui en paye le prix.
Il faut maintenir une relation
commerciale avec la Chine.
J'espère qu'on va pouvoir
revenir sur l'Arabie saoudite,
la vente d'armes, Raïf Badawi,
ça beaucoup de gens Québec.
- Merci beaucoup de votre
question que nous poursuivons
sur le thème de la Chine et sur
cette crise diplomatique. Depuis
10 mois maintenant, on vienne
faire mention de ça, il y a deux
Canadiens qui sont emprisonnés
en Chine en représailles à
l'arrestation de Meng Wanzhou,
la directrice financière de
wowis. Vous voulez durcir le ton
et imposer des tarifs douaniers,
est-ce que c'est la méthode de
M. Trump que vous imposez?
- C'est la méthode de l'inaction
de Justin Trudeau. Pendant cette
crise, il n'a rien fait. Il a
pris neuf mois pour nommer...
c'est seulement juste avant le
déclenchement des élections
qu'il a fait une crainte pour
les tribunaux mondiale du
commerce. Avec mon approche, on
va montrer au gouvernement de la
Chine qu'on va défendre nos
intérêts, on va défendre nos
producteurs agricoles et on va
défendre les Canadiens qui sont
détenus. Une chose que je dois
dire, excuse pendant cette crise
de ne pas s'ingérer dans
l'affaire Huawei, c'est que le
premier ministre ne peut pas
s'ingérer dans une poursuite
criminelle. Mais pendant
l'affaire SNC-Lavalin, c'est
Justin Trudeau qui s'est ingéré,
nuire notre position versus le
gouvernement de la Chine, parce
que M. Trudeau choseffrez autre
chose.
- Le Canada a à peu près le même
poids relatif face à la Chine,
les États-Unis, l'Europe, qu'il
a toujours eu. Les relations
commerciales avec l'Europe et
l'Asie ont fonctionné
relativement bien. Pourquoi
récemment ça signalé tout
croche, c'est parce que la
crédibilité de l'interlocuteur,
ça compte, n'est pas à la
hauteur. Il y a eu un discrédit
international, ce qui a fait
qu'il peut nier un communiqué,
se moquer du premier ministre du
Canada. C'est une question de
respect qu'un pays doit exiger.
- La politique étrangère du
Canada doit être axée sur la
prospérité et la sécurité des
Canadiens. Je suis le seul ici
sur le plateau qui est prêt à
faire en sorte à dire oui au
gouvernement Legault en ce qui
concerne l'immigration. Il y a
un seuil d'immigration plus bas
et se au plus d'immigrants
économiques, M. Scheer veut
avoir plus d'immigrants, il est
d'accord avec M. Trudeau à 350
000 par année, vous n'avez pas
de solution pour régler les gens
qui passent également par la
route de Roxham.
- M. Bernier, c'est clair, il
veut baisser les seuils
d'immigration. Vous verrez c'est
quoi votre position?
- J'ai fait une randonnée du
Québec. Dans chaque endroit j'ai
entendu la même chose, il y a
une pénurie de main-d'oeuvre.
Je vais travailler avec M.
Legault pour donner plus
d'autonomie au Québec pour
l'immigration. Je suis le seul
qui le fait. Avec plusieurs
députés bloquistes, on ne peut
pas le faire, parce que Justin
Trudeau va rester comme premier
ministre. Avec les sièges
bloquistes que ça va garantir
que Justin Trudeau va continuer
de ne faire aucune action pour
régler la situation à nos
frontières.
- Voter pour le bloc, c'est voté
pour les libéraux, voter pour le
bloc, c'est voter pour les
conservateurs. Voter pour le
bloc de ses voter pour le
Québec. M. Legault et le
gouvernement du Québec a demandé
clairement les pouvoirs en
immigration, en ce qui touche à
la sécurité. Vous devriez vous
engager, au Québec, notamment
pour les enjeux économiques.
- Vous aimez prétendre d'être le
honnêtement, soyons honnêtes,
après l'élection, vous allez
travailler pour qui?
(brouhaha)
- M. Blanchet... très bien, on
coupe les micros.
On peut couper?
voici le meilleur exemple d'une
cacophonie
Il n'est pas d'accord. Il veut
s'assurer d'apprendre un test de
valeur. Il est en train de dire
aujourd'hui qu'il va régler le
chemin Roxham. Si on veut
vraiment voir plus d'immigrants
de nature économique, il faut
moins de réfugiés. On veut aider
les vrais réfugiés.
- Merci Monsieur Bernier.
- 10 secondes à chacun de vous.
- Je vais prioriser les réfugiés
qui quittent la guerre civile
pas qui vienne de l'État de New
York.
- Qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire?
- Dans les endroits comme le
chemin Roxham, on va s'assurer
que notre système se concentre
sur...
- Il faut fermer le chemin
Roxham est passé par les vrais
posts frontaliers.
Il faut respecter la démocratie.
Les gens qui votent pour le bloc
ont le droit.
- Très bien. Autre trio.
Monsieur Singh, Madame May,
Monsieur Trudeau. On poursuit la
discussion sur l'immigration.
Est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
donner le pouvoir que le premier
du ministre du Québec vous
demande en immigration dans
l'histoire du test de valeur et
aussi la possibilité de baisser
les seuils pour une catégorie
d'immigrants?
- Monsieur Legault abaissait le
seuil d'immigration pour le
Québec parce que le Québec a
beaucoup de pouvoirs en matière
d'immigration plus que tout
autre province. C'est une bonne
chose à cause de l'identité
québécoise et la protection de
la langue. D'ailleurs, s'ils
veulent appliquer un test lors
du certificat de sélection,
c'est tout à fait correct et
c'est approprié qu'il le fasse.
On reconnaît l'importance que le
gouvernement du Québec ait
plus de contrôle sur
l'immigration, c'est quelque
chose que nous avons toujours
bien travaillé avec le
gouvernement du Québec depuis
quatre ans.
- Très bien.
- Les Verts, nous sommes
absolument ouverts de parler
avec Monsieur Legault
parce que nous sommes absolument
engagés de travailler avec la
nation de québécoise égal à
égal. À un niveau pont où notre
pays, nous sommes engagés pour
l'augmentation du niveau de
l'immigration à cause de deux
choses. Nous avons besoin
des travailleurs et
travailleuses et en même temps,
nous avons les obligations parce
que nous sommes un pays
industrialisé.
Nous avons contribué plus que
notre nombre de populations dans
une crise climatique et nous
avons le problème des réfugiés
climatiques.
- On est prêt à travailler avec
le Québec, c'est tellement
important. On doit mieux
financer l'intégration des gens.
Quelque chose ma hache allait un
peu. Monsieur Blanchet a dit de
voter pour le bloc, c'est voté
pour le Québec. Ça m'achale un
peu parce que le bloc, c'est
vous, mais le Québec, c'est une
diversité d'opinion, des
régions, une diversité des voix.
Vous n'avez pas le monopole sur
le Québec.
- D'ailleurs, j'allais justement
dire la même chose parce que je
suis fié québécois et je suis
fédéraliste et je suis fié
Canadiens. Ce qu'on a vu en
2015, c'est que les Québécois
ont choisi de faire parti d'un
gouvernement et c'est ça qui a
mis fin de 10 ans de Monsieur
Harper qui ne investissait pas
en culture, qui coupait partout,
qui proposait l'austérité. Les
Québécois doivent réfléchir très
clairement. Est-ce qu'ils
veulent faire partie d'un
gouvernement qui va continuer à
lutter contre les changements
climatiques, à travailler main
dans la main avec le Québec dans
les priorités communes?
C'est ce qu'on va continuer de
faire.
- En fait, vous êtes premier
ministre de vos petits amis.
Vous avez rencontré des secteurs
pétroliers 1500 fois et ce
n'était pas un simple vous avait
acheté un pipeline.
- Monsieur, permettez-moi, on
n'est pas sur le sujet.
On était sur l'immigration. J'ai
accepté parce que l'immigration,
le pouvoir du Québec, ça dépend.
Armand ne revient pas au
pipeline.
- Au sujet de l'immigration,
Monsieur Trudeau, vous avez fait
quelque chose que vous avez
promis de ne jamais faire et
c'est de cacher les lois dans
les projets de loi omnibus et
dans le dernier projet de loi
omnibus budgétaire, vous avez
cacher des choses avec la
violation des droits des
réfugiés. Nous avons des choses
qui arrêtent les droits humains,
annule les droits humains des
personnes qui veulent chercher
un refuge sécuritaire au Canada.
- C'est tout à fait faux. Nous
comprenons que les Canadiens
croient qu'on devrait avoir un
système rigoureux et équitable
qui s'applique à tout le monde
parlait en train de soulever
toutes les normes est en train
de mener l'normal international
pour protéger les droits de la
personne, pour s'assurer que
tout le monde qui arrive dans
nos frontières, que ce soit de
façon régulière ou irrégulière,
passe par l'intégrité de notre
système d'immigration. On a un
système fort qui continue à
s'appliquer mais il y a des gens
qui misent sur la peur et la
division.
- On a une solution claire pour
régler le problème de traverser
les frontières, c'est de
suspendre l'accord des tiers
pays surs. Mais vous n'avez pas
le courage de la faire parce que
vous avez pas le courage de
dénoncer Donald Trump teamé des
enfants dans des prisons. Vous
n'avez pas le courage de la
Donald Trump de suspendre cet
accord.
- On est dans une situation de
relations internationales. Les
relations avec les Américains,
c'est la relation la plus
importante pour un premier
ministre Canadiens et notre
pays. On a pu sécuriser l'ALÉNA
dans un moment de
protectionniste.
- Il y a des prêts sur la
gestion de leur. Vous avez
augmenté le prix des
médicaments.
- Merci. La question était
l'accord sur l'tiers pays sur,
est-ce qu'il peut s'ouvrir?
- On continue de travailler avec
les Américains.
- Alec Castonguay va se joindre
à moi, chef de bureau politique
de l'actualité. Bonsoir.
- Première question pour
Monsieur Trudeau. Plusieurs
citoyens nous ont écrit parce
qu'ils sont inquiets, préoccupés
par la cinquantaine de migrants
qui arrivent chaque jour sur le
chemin Roxham à la France. Est-
ce que c'est un problème pour
vous?
- Oui, c'est un problème. On est
dans un monde où 65 millions de
personnes sont des gens
déplacés. On reconnaît qu'on a
une responsabilité de passer ces
gens dans l'intégrité, de façon
rigoureuse à notre système
d'émigration et c'est ce qu'on
fait. On a fait des
investissements nécessaires. Il
n'y a pas de passe-droit à la
frontière. Tout le monde qui
vient de façon régulière ou
irrégulière à ces vérifications
de sécurité et passe dans toutes
les étapes de notre système
d'immigration.
- Merci Monsieur Trudeau. Madame
May. Le réchauffement climatique
est un problème planétaire et
non seulement Canada. Dans les
10 prochaines années, la Chine
prévoit ouvrir ces nouvelles
centrales au charbon chaque
mois. Comment s'assurer que les
efforts Canadiens ne sont pas
anéantis, annulé par les autres
pays?
- Ce n'est pas possible pour moi
de donner la garantie mais je
suis absolument certaine que si
le Canada reste comme maintenant
comme un pays industrialisé
riche qui s'est engagé
d'augmenter le niveau de gaz à
effet de serre, c'est impossible
pour nous de jouer un rôle dans
le monde, dans les négociations
des Nations unies.
Nous avons eu dans le temps
passé le rôle de leader.
Nous avons perdu ce rôle à cause
de notre échec contre les
désastres climatiques. Je suis
certain que nous pouvons encore
jouer un rôle comme leader.
- Monsieur Bernier, vous
souhaitez que le Canada
accueille moins d'immigrants,
moins de réfugiés, vous
souhaitez couper dans l'aide aux
pays pauvres, vous désengagez de
l'ONU. Est-ce que le Canada un
rôle à jouer dans le monde?
- Effectivement avec ses alliés
mais d'abord du côté des
Canadiens en premier. Vous avez
raison d'en parler, Monsieur
Trudeau a laissé sous-entendre
que notre position sur
l'immigration est une position
radicale. Lorsque 49 % des
Canadiens veulent un seuil plus
bas. On est le seul parti qui en
parle. Seulement 6 % des
gardiens veulent plus
d'émigration. Il y a un coût
social à avoir toujours plus et
plus d'émigration. Regardez les
maisons, le prix des maisons à
Toronto et aussi à Vancouver.
41 % des immigrants vont dans
ces villes et ça fait une
pression à la hausse. Il faut
avoir des seuils plus bas.
- Merci. Monsieur Scheer, vous
voulez diminue de 25 % l'aide
aux pays pauvres ce qui amène la
contribution canadienne à son
niveau de 1965. Est-ce que vous
ne tournez pas le dos à la
tradition canadienne?
- Pas du tout.
25 % de l'étranger à ce moment
vont à des pays avec des revenus
élevés. On va garder cet argent
ici pour rendre la vie plus
abordable pour les Canadiens. On
va payer pour notre baisse
d'impôt universel, c'est 850 $
pour un couple de revenus
moyens. On va éliminer la TPS
sur les factures à domicile
électricité. On va aussi avoir
notre plateformes toutes
chiffrées bientôt.
Monsieur Trudeau cache les
chiffres de plus de 50 % de ses
engagements.
- Monsieur Blanchet, vous avez
dit que le Canada aurait dû se
mêler de ses affaires et ne pas
arrêter la directrice financière
d'Huawei à la demande des États-
Unis. Selon vous, est-ce que la
règle de droit est négociable en
fonction de la puissance du
client ou du pays?
- Je crois que ce n'était pas
simple comme ça. La réalité est
que les États-Unis ont évoqué
des règles de droit qui rentrait
dans des notions de commerce, ce
n'est pas un geste criminel.
C'est complexe, c'est lié à des
sanctions que le Canada n'a pas
cautionnées. Lorsque tu
embarques sur une patinoire
comme ça contre un adversaire,
ça devient un adversaire aussi
puissant que la Chine et ce sont
des agriculteurs du Québec ou de
l'Ouest qui paie le prix de se
comporter de façon
irresponsable. Les Américains
n'ont pas voulu aider le Canada
par la suite.
- Comment on fait pour respecter
le traité si on ne répond pas
aux demandes?
- C'est lié à des sanctions
commerciales imposées par les
Américains qui n'étaient pas
liés à des gestes criminels.
- Monsieur Singh, chaque fois
que le Canada signe un accord
commercial que ce soit avec les
États-Unis ou l'Europe, NPD s'y
oppose. Êtes-vous
protectionniste?
- Pour moi, si l'échange donne
un avantage aux travailleurs
mais ce qu'on a vu avec Monsieur
Trudeau, il va avoir des
échanges et aussi avec Monsieur
Scheer comme conservateur, il
veut avoir des échanges qui
donnent tous les pouvoirs, les
bénéfices aux plus riches. Ça
n'aide pas du tout
l'travailleur. Ce que je veux
voir, ce sont des accords où on
donne des avantages pour les
travailleurs. Je ne travaille
pas pour les plus riches. Je
travaille pour vous, les gens.
- L'Europe et les États-Unis ont
quand même des valeurs qui
ressemblent au Canada pour les
travailleurs. Pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ces
accords?
- Par exemple, avec l'ALÉNA, on
a eu des prêches dans la gestion
de l'offre, une augmentation
dans le prix des médicaments et
pas de protection pour les
travailleurs et l'environnement.
- Merci beaucoup.
Prochain thème.
Identité, éthique et
gouvernance. Nous lançons le
thème avec une question d'une
citoyenne. Elle est à Montréal.
Lise Pichon, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir Patrice.
- Nous vous écoutons. Votre
question?
- J'ai 63 ans. Je suis atteinte
de sclérose en plaques depuis
près de 30 ans et surtout
d'arthrite sévère depuis 12 ans.
Je ne marche plus, je souffre et
je porte des culottes
d'incontinence. J'ai des plaies
de pression et j'en passe.
Afin de permettre à vos proches
et à nous tout un jour d'avoir
le droit de mourir dans la
dignité, promettez-vous aux
électeurs oui ou non
d'alléger la loi actuelle comme
le recommande la juge Baudouin
de la cour supérieure du Québec,
et ce sans créer d'embûches
supplémentaires?
Merci.
- Merci infiniment. Je vous
reviens après les réponses.
Madame May, vous êtes la
première à répondre.
- Je suis vraiment touché par
votre situation et je veux vous
donner mes sympathies et aussi
un engagement parce qu'on doit
changer cette loi. J'ai fait mes
efforts dans le Parlement, dans
l'étude du projet de loi pour
permettre l'aide à mourir
et la dignité, les droits des
citoyens de choisir de façon et
le moment de mourir en dignité.
Je veux faire encore la même
chose dans le prochain mandat.
- Merci. Monsieur Singh?
- Madame, ma réponse est oui.
Merci infiniment pour avoir le
courage de partager une question
si difficile et pour partager
votre histoire qui est aussi
tellement difficile. Ça prend
beaucoup de courage et je veux
vous remercier. C'est clair avec
le jugement au Québec que les
critères sont trop limités. Ça
ne donne pas la dignité. Ce que
je veux faire, c'est d'enlever
les limites parce que c'est trop
limité. Je vais vous donner plus
de pouvoir d'avoir le droit de
mourir dans la dignité. C'est
une décision difficile mais il
faut avoir accès à ce droit
important. Oui, je suis avec
vous et oui on peut le faire.
- Monsieur Blanchet.
- La réponse est très évidemment
oui. C'est un phénomène très
nouveau. C'est une philosophie
nouvelle au Québec comme au
Canada.
Je vous félicite et je félicite
les gens qui sont allés au
tribunal parce que vous vous
êtes emparé de cette loi, vous
avez dit que c'est à nous, on
veut participer à comment ça va
se vivre et comment ça va
s'appliquer. Je pense que les
gouvernements doivent s'engager
fermement à respecter le
jugement sans condition quitte à
travailler en parallèle par la
suite, a continué cette loi.
Mais il est essentiel que le
jugement soit respecté.
- Merci. Monsieur Trudeau.
- Merci pour votre question et
votre courage être avec nous ce
soir. C'est une question
extrêmement personnelle pour les
individus et les familles. Nous
devons être là en tant que
gouvernement pour vous aider à
naviguer ces questions
difficiles.
Oui, nous allons alléger la loi
dans les prochains six mois
parce que nous reconnaissons
depuis le début que c'était une
nouvelle loi, un équilibre qu'il
fallait chercher entre la
protection des plus vulnérables
et le respects des droits et des
choix de chacun et chacune. On
comprenait même il y a quatre
ans, quand on a amené cette loi,
que les tribunaux, la société,
tout allait évoluer et on va
évoluer avec. Merci pour votre
question.
- Monsieur Scheer.
- Merci beaucoup pour la
question. Bon courage. Vous avez
tous mes sympathies. C'est un
enjeu très personnel. Je dois
dire que c'est un des moments
que j'ai trouvés que tous les
partis au parlement ont vraiment
essayé de trouver un terrain
commun, la bonne voie pour
répondre aux décisions de la
cour. En même temps, trouver
l'équilibre pour protéger les
gens vulnérables et les choses
comme ça.
Pour moi, nous allons toujours
respecter les décisions de
cours. En même temps, on va
faire vu de la décision parce
que quand Monsieur Blanchet a
dit, c'est tellement nouveau
ici au Canada. On doit s'assurer
de trouver la bonne voie.
- Merci. Monsieur Bernier?
- Effectivement, cette loi doit
être révisée. Je peux vous dire
que j'ai voté en faveur au
fédéral de la loi pour mourir
avec dignité. La liberté et la
responsabilité individuelle, au
parti populaire, je m'apprête
effectivement à engager à
regarder cette législation et
s'assurer que les gens qui
prennent cette décision
difficile avec leur père soit
capables de faire ce qu'ils
veulent faire pour leur fin de
vie. Donc vous avez complètement
l'appui du parti populaire dans
vos démarches.
- Merci Monsieur Bernier et
merci surtout à Madame pigeon.
Vous êtes la plus courageux
d'entre nous ce soir. Merci
beaucoup.
(applaudissements)
Merci, merci beaucoup
d'avoir eu le courage de venir
Merci beaucoup d'avoir eu le
Je sais que ce n'était pas
facile nécessairement et c'est
un débat important.
Merci, Mme Jean. Bonne fin de
soirée.
Nous poursuivons avec la
première confrontation à trois.
M. Singh, M. Trudeau et M.
Bernier.
Inutile de vous dire qu'on a
reçu 1 t de questions sur la
laïcité. Je vous repose à vous
trois, et je le ferai aux trois
autres, la question assez
simplement. Allez-vous
intervenir dans la contestation
de la loi 21 sur la laïcité? Et
si oui, à quel état? Donnez-nous
des détails parce qu'on a
l'impression que vous êtes
tellement prudent pour ne pas
perdre de vote au Québec que ça
devient tellement confus, votre
discours, je vous en prie, soyez
clair. M. Singh, commence avec
vous.
- D'accord. J'étais toujours là.
Je ne veux pas intervenir
et ce que je veux faire, c'est
de toujours lutter contre le
concept de division. Je suis
compte évidemment l'idée de
discrimination. Moi, je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
font face a cette discrimination
dans leur vie, c'est
complètement inacceptable. Mais
je veux gagner le coeur des gen.
Je suis au Québec, je suis à
travers le pays et je parle aux
gens et je leur dis : je porte
un turban mais je suis pour les
droits à l'avortement, pour le
droit de mourir dans la dignité,
je suis pour la lutte aux
changements climatiques porte un
turban mais je partage vos
valeurs. C'est une question de
valeur. Si on veut protéger la
société, il faut renforcer les
droits des femmes, il faut
renforcer le droit d'avoir
l'avortement. Ça, c'est comment
on peut créer une société plus
juste et je suis prêt à le
faire.
- M. Trudeau?
- J'ai toujours été clairement
aussi que nous interviendrons
pas dans cette étape-ci parce
que c'est une question où les
Québécois sont en train de
mettre au défi devant les
tribunaux cette loi qu'il trouve
injuste. Mais je trouve aussi
que ce serait irresponsable pour
un gouvernement fédéral de
fermer la porte à tout jamais à
intervenir dans un cas d'une
état futur, dans un cas de
liberté et de droits
fondamentaux. On devrait être là
pour protéger les francophones
en dehors du Québec, on devrait
être là pour protéger les droits
des femmes, les droits des
communautés LGBT ou bien les
droits des minorités
religieuses. Je vais toujours
défendre les droits de tout le
monde et on verra aux prochaines
étapes
- M. Trudeau vient de nous dire
qu'il va intervenir et puis M.
Singh a dit le contraire de ce
qu'il avait dit en anglais
récemment. Moi, je peux vous
dire que j'ai une parole, et
laissez-moi terminer, je peux
vous dire que j'ai une parole en
on interviendra pas cette
décision du Québec. La laïcité
au Québec est un fait
maintenant. C'est passé dans une
législation. Il faut respecter
cela. Le Québec a sa propre
juridiction, à ses propres
compétences de passer une loi
sur la laïcité, et nous allons
la respecter, nous n'allons pas
intervenir comme à le faire M.
Trudeau comme il vient de le
dire, et M. Singh en anglais
avait dit le contrat. C'est
important de le souligner.
- M. Singh, vous aviez dit après
le dernier débat qu'à l'état de
la Cour suprême, vous
interviendrez. Pouvez-vous
préciser?
- J'ai respecté seulement un M.
Trudeau l'a dit. Il y a un fait
et je l'ai répété, et ce que
j'ai dit clairement, je ne veux
pas intervenir, il y a une
poursuite je ne veux pas
intervenir. Ce que je veux
faire, c'est de gagner le coeur
des gens. J'ai toujours dit ça
et je veux faire ça parce que je
sais que les politiques de
division, ce n'est pas bon pour
la société. Ça fait mal à la
société.
- J'ai été très clair qu'il y a
une possibilité de contestation
éventuelle de n'est pas garanti
parce que nous allons laisser
les étapes à suivre leur cours.
Pensez-y, je pense que les
Canadiens s'attendent à ce que
le gouvernement fédéral soit là
pour défendre les communautés
francophones si par exemple un
gouvernement majoritaire
conservateur de Doug Ford
s'attaque aux francophones en
Ontario. On s'attend que
gouvernement fédéral tienne
parole pour défendre les droits
des femmes conservateur de
renverser ses droits. On sera là
pour défendre les droits
fondamentaux de tout le monde.
- La conclusion est bien simple,
on veut intervenir, on veut
empêcher de faire en sorte que
le consensus au Québec, qui
existe, sur la loi de la laïcité
ne soit pas respecté. Et c'est
votre position. Un fédéral qui
va intervenir, le gouvernement
fédéral qui va dire au Québec
concernant ses propres champs de
compétences, et nous, au Parti
populaire, on veut respecter, M.
Trudeau, la Constitution. On ne
veut pas s'ingérer. Le Québec a
pris une décision, le
gouvernement a pris une décision
avec le courage politique que
Legault et le gouvernement du
Québec a. Il y a consensus
respecter ça. Quand vous dîtes
que cette loi est
discriminatoire, c'est injuste.
- M. Trudeau a touché les droits
des femmes. C'est une chose
qu'on protège droits des femmes
et d'autres choses de le faire.
On ne va prendre maintenant, ils
sont en train de fermer le seul
endroit où on a accès aux
services du droit à
l'avortement. Et vous n'avez
rien fait pour protéger l'accès
aux services d'avortement au
Nouveau Monde. Comment vous
pouvez dire une chose publique,
oui, je suis pour les droits,
mais en privé ce que vous faites
ce n'est pas la même chose.
- Sur la dernière ligne
avortement privée effectivement?
- Nous sommes préoccupés par la
décision du gouvernement
conservateur au Nouveau-
Brunswick qui retourne en
arrière sur les droits des
femmes. On avait travaillé avec
l'ancien gouvernement libéral
Nouveau-Brunswick pour améliorer
l'accès à l'avortement. Là, on
voit un gouvernement
conservateur qui s'est fait
élire, qui n'est pas là pour
défendre les droits des femmes.
Et c'est le danger avec M.
Scheer, il ne sera pas là pour
défendre les droits des.
- Merci beaucoup. Deuxième trio
sur le sujet. On va poursuivre
avec Mme May, M. Scheer et M.
Blanchet. Je vais rapidement, on
va rester sur l'avortement et on
va revenir à la laïcité. Je veux
rester sur l'avortement. M.
Scheer, vous engagez-vous à
améliorer l'accès à l'avortement
malgré vos convictions pro-vie?
- Pour la dernière fois, je vais
dire ça. J'ai toujours été clair
sur cette question. Je suis
personnellement pro-vie, mais on
ne va pas changer l'accès ou les
lois. C'est la même chose
pendant les derniers premiers
ministres libéraux, les
conservateurs n'ont pas changé.
Sous mon leadership, si je suis
premier ministre, va pas changer
les lois ou l'accès, c'est tout.
- Voilà. M. Blanchet, je reviens
sur la laïcité. J'ai une
question pour vous et j'ai une
question pour vous et je vais
relancer le trio.
Si la Cour suprême invalidait la
loi québécoise sur la laïcité,
en tout ou en partie, est-ce que
selon vous ça relancerait
l'option souverainiste?
- Je ne sais pas ce que les
Québécois feraient dans ce cas,
mais pour les Québécois, la
notion de laïcité, c'est une
valeur progressiste. C'est
hérité de la révolution
tranquille, c'est généreux,
accueillant, c'est bienveillant,
ça protège l'égalité de tout le
monde que ça protège égalité des
sexes, ce n'est pas quelque
chose de contraignant ou
d'restrictif dans le carré la
taille des Québécois. J'apprécie
ce qui reconnaisse que sa Québec
de décider. Je comprends les
ambiguïtés, M. Singh, vous
n'êtes pas la même chose en
anglais et en français. Les
journalistes voudront
travailler, ça n'a pas donné la
même chose. Et quand on parle
laïcité, Monsieur Trudeau nous
parle de Nouveau-Brunswick et du
droit à l'avortement. Les
Québécois sont capables d'avoir
déjà pour lesquels il n'y a pas
de doute sur la question de la
laïcité. Est-ce que des gens qui
souhaiteraient virer d'abord par
la Cour suprême diraient : on a
été négligé? Il y a eu un manque
de respect institutionnel par la
plus haute instance juridique du
Canada. Il y en a sûrement qui
se poserait la question, mais je
suis convaincu que tel n'est pas
l'intention du gouvernement
Legault, qui n'est pas un
gouvernement un gouvernement
souverainiste.
- Il y a seulement qui peut être
premier ministre qui a toujours
été clair sur cette question. On
ne veut pas intervenir. Ce n'est
pas veut pas mais va pas. C'est
ma position au premier jour de
la campagne de ma position
aujourd'hui, et ça va être ma
position après l'élection. C'est
clair que la priorité de M.
Blanchet, c'est de réanimer le
mouvement souverainiste. Il va
travailler avec le Parti
québécois, le lendemain après
l'élection, pour relancer les
débats pour un autre référendum.
Sa priorité était clair.
- Madame?
- Moi non plus je ne peux pas
intervenir mais je pense que
c'est un peu bizarre dans ces
élections fédérales, je suis
d'accord avec Chantal Hébert qui
a dit aujourd'hui que ce n'était
pas un enjeu dans l'élection
fédérale. Et nous avons eu le
débat au sujet d'une loi 21.
Je pense que la crise
climatique, en toute élection,
pour sa je suis inquiète,
j'espère que le Québec comme
nation reste une société
inclusive. Je pense que c'est
une question pour le Québec et
les Québécois et Québécoises,
mais maintenant, s'il vous
plaît, nous avons, il reste à
discuter ce qui se passe pour
les personnes dans le nord du
Canada, dans l'Arctique, pour
les personnes dans la région
atlantique, pour les fermiers.
Ce n'est pas dans les débats.
- Seulement quelques secondes
sur ça parce que M. Trudeau a
dit quelque chose de tellement
bizarre. On parle de la loi 21
au Québec. Il a commencé à
parler des autres enjeux dans
les autres provinces. Il était
obsédé des politiques
provinciales de l'Ontario. Il a
même mélangé une menace
hypothétique pour justifier sa
position incohérente sur cet
enjeu.
- Ne faites pas de commentaires
sur les affaires bizarres parce
que vous n'en, vous aussi. Vous
êtes en train...
Je ne suis pas Justin Trudeau,
ne me coupez pas la parole aux
trois secondes. Est en train de
dire que le gouvernement Legault
cette année sûrement une
tactique bloquiste qui va
soutenir la loi 21 pour faire
avancer le bloc et que le
lendemain, le bloc va aller
travailler avec les neufs
députés du parti québécois
contre le gouvernement Legault?
Alors que la dernière fois que
j'ai vérifiée, le 21 octobre, ce
n'est pas un référendum sur la
semaine, c'est élection fédéral
et le Bloc québécois audio
québécois : n'envoyez pas à
Ottawa des gens qui vont défaire
ce que vous avez demandé à ceux
de Québec de faire.
- Ce que j'ai dit, ce que vous
prétendez être le meilleur
ennemi de M. Trudeau. Vous
cachez vos interactions
actuelles pour garder des sièges
pour réanimer le mouvement
souverainiste le lendemain des
élections. Ça, c'est votre
priorité.
La priorité est d'améliorer la
qualité de tous les Canadiens,
de baisser les impôts, de rendre
la vie plus abordable. C'est ma
priorité.
- Arrêtez de vous chicaner!
S'il vous plaît, j'ai le droit
de parler un peu, s'il vous
plaît.
- Mme May, allez-y.
- Sur la question de la loi 21,
je pense que tous les chefs
problème parce que tout le monde
y au niveau fédéral, sauf pour
M. Blanchet, de monnaie pour les
lois mais en même temps, on doit
respecter le Québec et la
décision de l'eau. On doit
attendre les décisions de
contestations qui sont
maintenant d'être entrées au
Québec.
- Merci. Mme May, vous allez en
parler. Question en rafale
maintenant. Il a été beaucoup
question de cette histoire au
cours des derniers mois sur la
scène politique canadienne.
Alors je vous pose la même
question à tous. Souhaitez-vous,
souhaitez-vous, un accord de
réparation pour SNC-Lavalin?
Pour que l'entreprise que je le
rappelle pour le bénéfice des
gens à la maison, pour que
l'entreprise ne soit pas obligée
d'être condamnée à ne plus
recevoir, s'il y a condamnation,
des contrats publics pendant 10
ans? Premier à répondre, M.
Bernier.
- Nous sommes le seul parti, je
suis le seul qui était à
l'époque qu'il n'y a aucune
corporation qui est au-dessus de
la loi, aucune entreprise qui
est au-dessus de la loi. Donc le
gouvernement de M. Trudeau a
installé dans la législation
canadienne une clause qui permet
d'avoir des ententes spéciales
avec des compagnies corrompues.
Nous, nous sommes contre cela.
Toutes les compagnies doivent
être traitées de la même façon.
SNC-Lavalin comme les autres. Et
ça, c'est très important parce
que si vous ne faites pas ça,
les compagnies et les gens vont
perdre confiance dans notre
système juridique. Donc nous,
les petites compagnies sont
poursuivies lorsqu'il arrive
quelque chose, les grandes, ça
va être la même chose aussi.
- M. Singh?
- S'être tellement disait de
dire ça, mais ça va être la
seule dans ma vie que je suis
d'accord avec M. Bernier.
Dans ce cas, oui.
- Il fallait un dernier débat
pour ça!
- Le résultat de ce qui s'est
passé, M. Trudeau a essayé
d'aider les PDG, pas les
travailleurs et travailleuses,
ce qu'il a dit, il est un
premier ministre pour ses petits
amis. Il rencontre les grandes
compagnies, les aides, il peut
les appeler, il lui demande.
Aidez-moi. Et il les aide. Je
vais travailler pour les gens,
je veux travailler pour les
travailleurs et travailleuses.
Ça veut dire qu'on a un système
de justice qui est juste.
- M. Trudeau?
- Presque tous nos pays alliés,
en Europe et ailleurs, un
système d'entente de réparation
qui permet à une compagnie de
payer des pénalités, de changer
son comportement sans punir les
travailleurs qui n'avaient rien
à faire avec les décisions des
hauts cadres. C'est une
situation qui protège les
travailleurs quand il y a de la
malfaisance au niveau d'une
compagnie. C'est un système qui
fonctionne à travers le monde,
mais la décision que si ça va
être donné à une compagnie ici
au Canada appartient uniquement
au procureur général et au
ministre de la Justice, et nous
allons respecter cette décision
quand elle sera prise.
- M. Blanchet.
- Beaucoup de choses sont à
faire dans cette démarche de
réparation. M. Trudeau qui avait
planté une démarche fonctionner
même s'il est exact que les
grands pays occidentaux en
général ont de telles ententes
de réparation à même leur propre
législation. Il faudra réparer
la mauvaise habitude, et je vois
que M. Bernier ajoutait sa M.
Singh aussi, de jouer le Québec
corrompu. Les 3400 employés de
SNC-Lavalin actuelle et la
direction actuelle de SNC-
Lavalin n'a rien fait de pas
correct. Les actions temps, les
morceaux vont être vendus, les
travailleurs se cherchent des
emplois et c'est un autre
fleuron dégénérée québécoise qui
va tomber à cause écurie ou de
la mauvaise foi des parties
fédéralistes.
- M. Scheer?
- Un fleuron de notre pays,
c'est l'indépendance de notre
système judiciaire. Trudeau a
essayé de s'ingérer dans la
décision indépendante de son
procureur général. Il n'a pas
obtenu le résultat, la décision
qu'il voulait, il a congédié. Il
a essayé de s'ingérer et de
nuire à notre système
indépendant judiciaire. La
décision doit rester avec le
procureur général. Et les
excuses, les emplois, il y a
seulement un emploi, une job que
le premier ministre a voulu
sauver, et c'est la sienne.
- Mme May?
- Oui, je suis avec mon
collègue, M. Scheer. Je suis
d'accord avec M. Bernier. Aucune
entreprise ni personne n'est au-
dessus de la loi. Et c'est pour
ça que je suis déçue de M.
Trudeau parce qu'il a brisé la
loi avec la pression contre
notre procureur général, et en
même temps, le même projet de
loi omnibus dont j'ai parlé dans
l'autre section, c'est dans le
même projet omnibus budgétaire
où ils ont changé le Code
criminel pour aider SNC-Lavalin.
Ça, ce n'est pas la façon de
faire les bonnes décisions.
- Merci. Un débat ouvert qui
commence. Je vous lance une
question et ensuite les réponses
sont à vous bien sûr. C'est dans
les crises qu'on mesure le
jugement et la transparence d'un
chef. Vous avez tous ou à peu
près tous dû passait l'éponge
sur des candidats, dans certains
cas vous avez dû en renvoyer.
Des candidats embarrassants. À
partir de maintenant, est-ce que
vous nous dîtes que c'est
tolérance zéro pour un candidat
ou un député éventuellement pour
toute remarque qui serait jugée
raciste? M. Blanchet?
- D'abord, je comprends très
bien pourquoi cette question est
là aujourd'hui. Si n'importe
quelle des candidats qui ont été
mis en cause avaient refusé de
s'excuser de façon explicite, il
ne serait plus un candidat du
Bloc québécois parce que je peux
affirmer, je suis convaincu que
mes énormes réseaux sociaux, mon
passé de chroniqueur, mon passé
à l'émission les Ex tous a été
scruté. Personne ne peut douter
que je sois n'importe quoi qui
soit un petit peu proche de
raciste. Je n'aurais eu aucune
espèce de tolérance et je
comprends que les collègues et
fait la même chose dans un
certain nombre de cas. Il me
semble essentiel dans une
campagne électorale que les gens
choisissent pour qui ils vont
voter en fonction des valeurs
qui vont être portées et c'est
de ça dont il faut parler. Nous,
de tout coeur, on va travailler
pour le Québec.
- Vous avez vu quatre exemples
de gens qui excuser, M. Scheer
ou Seadogs M. Trudeau. M.
Scheer?
- Je peux vous dire qu'il y a un
candidat qui n'a jamais été
passé maintenant notre système
de vérification pour analyser
les candidats, c'est le candidat
qui a brisé la loi sur l'éthique
de foi, c'est une candidate qui
a menti souvent, qui a menti sur
beaucoup de choses dans sa vie.
Et ça, c'est le candidat libéral
de Papineau.
- Les excuses sont importants
mais les gestes et les
intentions, et les valeurs sont
importantes aussi. On va
toujours juger selon les
priorités, les valeurs et les
actions de tous et de chacun. Ça
fait parti du choix électoral
que les gens font. Est-ce que
les gens représentent leur
valeur? Je pense que les gens
savent que depuis quatre ans, je
les défends et on va continuer
d'avancer en les défendant.
- Nous ne sommes pas parfaits,
je ne suis pas parfait, les
candidats ont fait des erreurs.
L'importance que les candidats
assument ses erreurs là et s'il
y a lieu à des excuses, oui,
c'est parfait. Mais après ça, on
doit s'assurer que ces gens-là
partagent les valeurs
canadiennes, les valeurs
d'équité, de tolérance et c'est
ce qui est important pour nous.
Notre parti est fondé sur des
principes clairs : l'équité, la
tolérance et le respect. On veut
que nos candidats fassent la
même chose et ils ne font.
- En fait, c'est une question
d'authenticité. Si quelques
excuses, mais qui ne s'engage
pas à changer pour l'avenir, il
n'y a pas un engagement formel
de faire des choses différentes,
donc non. Mais si cette personne
excuse et qu'il a aussi un
engagement de changer, et aussi
si quelqu'un partage nos
valeurs, il dans la partie. Nos
valeurs c'est de travailler pour
les gens, pas pour les plus
riches. Nos valeurs sont de
travailler pour défendre les
droits de la personne que nos
valeurs sont vraiment avancées
la justice sociale en même temps
on va combattre la crise
climatique. On peut le faire
ensemble. Exactement la somme
des candidats et d'équipe qu'on
a et c'est justement ce dont les
Canadiens ont besoin.
- Je pense que nous avons un
problème dans notre démocratie.
Plusieurs personnes ont demandé
pourquoi quelqu'un, un citoyen
va se présenter pour un parti
dans notre démocratie? Parce
qu'il y a toujours des choses
qui sont embarrassantes. Pour
moi-même, c'est une question du
niveau de leur commentaire. Nous
avons dans la Parti vert zéro
tolérance pour le racisme,
antisémitisme, sexisme. C'est
clair. Mais on doit réfléchir
parce que ces élections, dans
les dernières quatre semaines,
nous avons pris le temps, la
grande majorité du temps, avec
la petite politique, pas pour le
dialogue, pour aider tout le
monde, trouver la façon de
travailler ensemble contre
l'urgence climatique. Et jusqu'à
mon dernier souffle, je veux
essayer d'arrêter l'urgence
climatique.
- Il faut travailler ensemble,
il faut qu'on fasse un bon
choix, qu'on avance, il faut
lutter contre les changements
climatiques. On va continuer
d'avancer.
- M. Scheer M. Blanchet et
ensuite nous terminons.
- Le choix de cette élection,
c'est clair. Quatre années avec
les hauts impôts, la vie devient
plus chère ou une pratique,
Parti conservateur avec moi qui
vaux vous rendre la vie plus
abordable.
- Conserve au parlement, on
votera ce qui est bon pour le
Québec, on votera contre ce qui
est mauvais pour le Québec.
- Mesdames et Messieurs merci.
Madame, messieurs les chefs,
merci à vous. Dans l'ensemble,
vous avez été discipliné. Merci.
21 octobre, jour du vote,
Mesdames et Messieurs. C'est un
rendez-vous pour la grande
soirée électorale sur toutes les
plates-formes de Radio-Canada.
Merci de votre attention, merci
à toute l'équipe derrière. La
prochaine fois
(applaudissements)
Sous-titrage : SRC 2019